Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Letzter Donnerstag im Monat. Einmal zählen lernen. Das bedeutet, dass wir beim Chaosradio in Blumen sind. Dazu herzlich willkommen. Das letzte Chaosradio in diesem Jahr, wo es quasi um ein Thema geht, das dem Namen Chaosradio schon enthalten ist, nämlich um die Produktion von Audioinhalten und zwar in einer Art und Weise, die es möglicherweise jedem möglich macht, diese Audioinhalte irgendwie zur Verfügung zu stellen. Mit anderen Worten, es geht heute um Podcasten und wir erklären mal, wie das geht, was man dazu benutzt, was man machen kann, was man vielleicht lieber bleiben lassen sollte und dazu habe ich drei Leute hier im Studio vom Chaos Computer Club und von einem Podcast. Das sind erstens Maha und Elektra. Maha ist hier, weil er zwei Podcasts hat, nämlich den Klabauta-Cast und die Liedkultur. Warum, was, wie und so weiter erklären wir auch. Und Elektra ist hier, weil es bei diesem ganzen wir streuen Audio, selbstgemachtes Audio und das Volk ja möglicherweise auch immer noch dieses alte, gar nicht netzaffine UKW-Ding gibt, wo das ja möglicherweise auch gerade diese Sendung hört. Und Elektra hat sich damit beschäftigt, wie man das im Selbstbau möglicherweise machen kann, richtig?
Radiokommunikation im weitesten Sinne ist mein Lieblingsfeld.
Und wir erklären auch mal, wie weit man das überhaupt darf. Ein bisschen zumindest. Und dann ist noch Nicolas Seemark hier, der einen eigenen Podcast hat, Elementarfragen heißt der, und der deswegen hier ist, um mal genau zu erklären, wie man sagen als, ich sag mal nichts Ahnen, da zum Thema Podcasts kommt. Guten Abend. Und was man alles machen muss, damit das funktioniert. Und es ist ja so, das Chaosradio hatte schon eine sehr, sehr, sehr lange Geschichte. Und naja, möglicherweise ist es auch mehr oder weniger einer der ersten Podcasts, die es hier in Deutschland vielleicht gab. Und der Name Podcasting damals und heute ist verbunden mit einem Namen eines Typen, der sehr viel in dieser Richtung unterwegs ist. Und mit dem wollen wir jetzt zuerst mal eine kurze Rückschau und Vorschau vielleicht halten. Das ist nämlich Tim Prittlor, den wir noch ans Telefon geholt haben. Hallo und guten Abend. Hallo. Das erste Mal, was ich fragen muss, der Mythos Chaosradio, den ich verbinde, ist, dass es diese Sendung vor allem deswegen gibt, weil der Club irgendwann dachte so, hey, so Audioproduzieren ist geil, lass doch mal so ein Studio entern.
Das ist der Mythos? Ja, also nicht ganz falsch jetzt.
Was soll ich dazu sagen?
Also die Idee kam halt mal so auf, als so der Club und Fritz was zu tun hatten, so ganz indirekt. Ich war gerade im Urlaub und wurde dann vorher verletzt und anbestellt.
Aber das ist ja schon ein paar Jährchen her. War es damals sozusagen so, dass die Audiotechnik, die man brauchte, um so ein Audio zu produzieren, einfach noch zu teuer war? Also sagen jetzt nicht für jeden irgendwie mal eben ins eigene Wohnzimmer stellbar?
Ich glaube, von der Zeit hat einfach niemand im Entferntesten darüber nachgedacht, selber jetzt Radio zu machen, im Sinne von ohne einen Radiosender Radio zu machen. Sondern es hat sich einfach nur diese Gelegenheit ergeben, eben genau diesen Slot da zu bespielen, der ja auch heute noch bespielt wird. Und den haben wir dann einfach genutzt.
Und da sozusagen diese Sendung gibt es auch schon relativ lange, dann auch als Download, also quasi so eine Art Podcast. Würdest du sagen, dass die Möglichkeiten, die du heute als Podcaster bei dir in deinem also fast schon professionellen Studio hast, den hier bei Fritz im Studio mithalten können?
Leider noch nicht ganz. Aber das hat es mittlerweile eigentlich nur noch meiner Faulheit geschuldet, beziehungsweise der Tatsache, dass ich nicht 30 Stunden am Tag arbeiten kann. Aber man kann das schon ganz gut nachbilden.
Und glaubst du, dass es Radio noch geben wird in Zukunft, oder wird das mit dem Podcast möglicherweise so überhandnehmen?
Ich finde, das schließt sich alles gar nicht so richtig aus. Das ist so ein bisschen wie mit Bloggen und Zeitungen, so eine etwas sinnlose Diskussion. Weil es deckt einfach erstmal ganz andere Bedürfnisse ab. Podcasten ist ja einfach überhaupt gar kein Formatradio, kein Zeitradio, kein Live-Radio, zumindest nicht normalerweise. Es wird ganz anders, es ist redaktionell ganz anders, es ist einfach anders. Podcasting ist einfach die Möglichkeit selber einfach Audio oder eben auch Video zu machen und sich Formate auch selber auszudenken, die mit so einem normalen Radio keine Chance hätten. Vor allem, man hat einfach diese ganzen Limitierungen nicht. Man hat nicht diese Limitierung, dass es eben nur diesen einen Kanal gibt pro Sender, den man da föhnen kann und alle prügeln sich um die Plätze. Es ist einfach eine Ergänzung und ich denke, als Apple mal angefangen hat, dieses Podcasting in iTunes einzubauen, dann haben sie so die Tagline verwendet Radio Reborn und das fand ich eigentlich ganz treffend, weil es eigentlich eher so eine Neugeburt des Radios ist. Es gibt jetzt einfach viel mehr Leute, die erwägen, selber Radio zu machen. Und das auch können, unabhängig von der UKW-Landschaft.
Da wollte ich jetzt gerade fragen, wenn jetzt jemand sich denkt, so Podcasten würde ich eigentlich auch anfangen, würdest du ihm das empfehlen? Und wenn ja, wie fängt man es am besten an? In drei Sätzen.
Also man muss das erstmal wollen. Im Sinne von empfehlen kann man das halt demjenigen, der was zu sagen hat. Also ein bisschen enttäuschend finde ich immer so Projekte, wo man das Gefühl hat, wo man dann am Ende überhaupt gar nicht weiß, wollen die mir jetzt eigentlich was mitteilen oder hören sie sich nur selber gerne reden? Und im letzten Fall sollte man das halt vielleicht beisiedigen. Dann muss man das nicht unbedingt, würde ich das jetzt nicht unbedingt empfehlen, man kann es natürlich trotzdem machen. Also man kann es natürlich auch machen, wenn man sich einfach gerne selber reden hört. Das ist ja auch in Ordnung.
Die Frage ist dann nur, ob es dann jemand hört.
Ja, ich finde, es macht einen riesen Unterschied aus, wenn man jetzt Programme von jemanden hört, ob da auch wirklich so ein Mitteilungsbedürfnis mit wirklich verbunden ist. Und ob man es schafft, so eine Ansprache auch zu formulieren, die einfach mitschwingt. Ich finde, man merkt das einfach sofort, wenn Leute wirklich da was heraus kommunizieren wollen und eben das Gegenüber auch im Kopf haben, während sie reden.
Das heißt also für die Sendung heute, wo wir ja im Prinzip sprechen wollen, ob das Radio für alle schon Wirklichkeit geworden ist, hat uns jetzt Tim, den ersten Schritt, den wir dazu brauchen, schon mal gesagt, nämlich man muss was zu sagen haben. Tim, dir auf jeden Fall vielen Dank und viel Spaß. Jetzt schmeißen wir dich schon wieder raus. Verrücktes Backofenzeug, oder? Genau, aber du hast ja auch ganz viele Podcasts. Du hast auch einen über das Podcasten, wie heißt der?
Der heißt der Lautsprecher.
Der Lautsprecher, da kann man ganz genau hören, was der Tim zum Podcast noch zu sagen hat. Da gibt es auch die ganze Technik und so weiter und so fort. Dir auf jeden Fall vielen Dank und viel Spaß beim Radio Neugebären. Und wie gesagt, den ersten Punkt haben wir jetzt für Podcasten und Radio selber machen, nämlich was zu sagen haben. Wie gesagt, zur Elektra kommen wir dann später mit dem UKW. Jetzt erstmal, ihr beiden, Nikolas, Maha, warum habt ihr angefangen zu Podcasten? Also was hattet ihr zu sagen?
Na ja, gut, es gab verschiedene Sachen. Einmal war ich natürlich auch inspiriert von Tim. Von daher passt das ganz gut. Und da hab mir gedacht, Mensch, der Tim macht immer so sehr technik-nahe Kultur. Also mit Chaosradio Express. Und ich hab gedacht, da müsste es doch auch eine Möglichkeit geben, noch ein bisschen was anderes an Kultur zu machen. Also das, was ein bisschen weiter von der Technik entfernt ist. Und so hab ich dann eben die Idee gehabt, Liedkultur zu machen. Also Liedkultur.de eben auch über Kultur. Im Allgemeinen, aber eben schon aus der Perspektive der Nerds. Also das war da so meine Idee. Und der andere, der Club Outercast, das ist ja nun ein Podcast, wo es um Politik geht. Ich bin ja irgendwann dann zu den Piraten gekommen. Also jetzt nicht zu den Leuten, die Piratenradio machen, sondern eben zu der politischen Partei, der Gleichnamigen. Und da hatte ich auch sofort das Bedürfnis, ich muss mich irgendwie einbringen durch Inhalte. Und dann habe ich gedacht, okay, dann mache ich einen Podcast. Eigentlich habe ich es vor allem deshalb gemacht, weil ich diesen schönen Namen hatte. Also ich hatte mir gedacht, Club Outercast müsste das dann heißen. Und wenn man einen Namen hat, dann muss man auch Inhalte nachliefern.
Warum diese Form Podcast? Also du hättest dich ja auch sozusagen irgendwie schriftlich äußern können. Oder du hast ja auch schon gesagt, du bloggst ja auch. Warum dann dieses Audioding?
Ja, ich blogge schon ziemlich lange. Aber das Bloggen ist schon, naja, man kann nicht so informell das machen. Also ich bin ja nun auch Sprachwissenschaftler. Und dann kommt es mir immer auch darauf an, dass ich da die richtige Formulierung habe und so. Und ich brauche immer sehr lange für meine Blogbeiträge. Und beim Podcasten geht es eigentlich schneller. Da schalte ich einfach das Aufnahmegerät an. Also am Anfang zumindest. Inzwischen habe ich einen gewissen technischen Anspruch und verbringe natürlich mehr Zeit damit. Aber am Anfang war das eben sehr einfach. Man schaltet den Computer an, spricht da rein und dann fällt sofort der Inhalt raus. Inzwischen machen wir sehr viel Aufwand. Das mache ich auch nicht alleine. Da gibt es halt noch einen Techniker, den ich habe, den Christopher Schirner, der dann auch noch hergeht und das Ganze aufbereitet und sich auch sehr, sehr viel Mühe gibt. Und dann kriegen wir auch was raus, was ein bisschen anspruchsvoller von der Technik her ist. Aber zunächst mal erschien es mir einfacher, einfach mal drauf loszusprechen.
Wie war das bei dir, Nicolas?
Also erstmal finde ich es ganz toll, dass die Sendung heute Piraten Sender Powerplay heißt. Weil dieser Film, der damals mit Mike Krüger und Thomas Gottschalk lief, für mich so eine Inspiration war, Radio zu machen. Also ich habe dann als Kind immer schon mit kleinen Kassettenrekordern rumgespielt und da reingesprochen. Insofern bin ich wahrscheinlich einer von denen, Tim sagt, dass er sich gerne selber reden hört. Ja, und dann als das mit dem Podcast anfing, also als in Deutschland auch die ersten angefangen haben, damit habe ich erstmal so ein Quatschprojekt gestartet, was dann bis heute eigentlich ganz gut läuft. Mikrodeletanten sitzen eigentlich drei Leute zusammen und unterhalten sich über Quatsch. Und irgendwann war mir das aber nicht genug und dann habe ich eine Interviewsendung angefangen. Die heißt Elementarfragen und da halte ich mich eigentlich relativ zurück mit eigenen Sprachbeiträgen. Sondern ich stelle eher Fragen und porträtier da im Zweifel die Gesprächspartner ein bisschen.
Das hört sich jetzt so an, wie du hattest eigentlich das Bedürfnis, irgendwo hin irgendjemandem ein Audio zu bewerfen und hast ja dann quasi eine Ausrede dafür gesucht.
Sozusagen, ja. Okay. Nee, eigentlich nicht. Aber da würde ich jetzt ungern ja einfach zu sagen. Nee, ich finde halt diese Idee des Sentences einfach toll. Es war wahrscheinlich so ein Sendebedürfnis ein bisschen. Und im Endeffekt ist es ja auch Kommunikation. Und das ist glaube ich das Spannende bei Podcasts, dass du eben auch guten Rückkanal einbauen kannst. Eben durch Kommentare in dem jeweiligen Blog dann und so weiter. Das finde ich halt auch spannend. Also höherer Kontakt und nicht in so einem Elfenbeinturm, wie wir hier jetzt gerade sitzen, im Sendestudio zu sein.
Man kann hier auch, es gibt bei Chaosradio.de jeden Blog, da kann man Kommentare. Und es gibt einen ERC-Kanal auf Freenode. Da könnt ihr auch irgendwie gerne unter Fritze natürlich in den Kommentaren was reintun.
Wenn wir dann hier auch Internet tappen, können wir ja auch lesen. Ich nicht. Aber das ist glaube ich auch nochmal ein wichtiger Punkt, der Rückkanal. Also ich denke, das habe ich vorhin auch nicht gesagt. Das Feedback ist eigentlich sozusagen die Belohnung, die man hat. Wir machen das ja alle freiwillig und ohne Entgelt.
Du machst das freiwillig?
Ja, naja, ich verdiene damit nichts. Ich weiß ja nicht, wie das bei dir ist. Aber dann freut man sich natürlich über Kommentare und Feedback. Und das ist eigentlich ganz toll. Und das ist eben noch besser, wenn man gleichzeitig noch Streaming macht. Weil man dann direkt im Chat mit den Leuten direkt kommunizieren kann. Die können Fragen stellen, die kann man gleich beantworten. Das heißt, man hat nicht nur seine Gesprächspartner, sondern man hat auch gleichzeitig noch das Feedback aus dem Netz. Und das finde ich eigentlich besonders reizvoll.
Dann zum Streaming würde ich gerne später nochmal kommen. Erstmal zu sagen, die Idee, man ist motiviert. Okay, ich will jetzt irgendwie dieses Ding aufnehmen. Und dann ist es so, es schwingt jetzt schon so mit. Okay, diese Technik ist also nicht möglicherweise für jeden erschwinglich, aber doch erschwinglicher als noch von ein paar Jahren. Womit habt ihr angefangen zu podcasten? Also was war das Equipment? Und was habt ihr im Laufe der Zeit festgestellt, ist das Mindestequipment, was man braucht, um eine einigermaßen annehmbare Aufnahme hinzukriegen? Womit hast du angefangen?
Na ja, angefangen habe ich, ja doch, ich habe schon vielleicht ziemlich aufwendig angefangen. Also ich hatte so ein kleines Aufnahmegerät, so ein Digitalrekorder, und da habe ich dann reingesprochen. Und das konnte man dann schon nehmen. Also das ist das Erste. Aber dann habe ich natürlich später mir dann ein Headset zugelegt, weil das einfach dann besser ist. Aber eigentlich, also es gibt Leute, die machen halt so ein Podcast, in dem sie einfach in ihren Computer reinsprechen. Auch das geht. Das ist natürlich dann nicht qualitativ so hochwertig, aber im Grunde braucht man nichts, außer einen Computer mit einem Mikrofon. Und das war es eigentlich schon.
Das ist eine spannende Ansicht. Das ist auch der Punkt, wo ich sagen möchte, ihr seid natürlich auch herzlich eingeladen hier anzurufen.
Eure Meinung jetzt anrufen.
0331 70 97 110.
Weil ich das ja spannend finde, dass ich selber nehme Podcasten so wahr, dass als es anfing, gab es sehr viele Podcasts, die halt sagen, also nur mit dem internen Mikrofon vor dem Notebook aufgenommen wurden oder über eine ganz schlechte Skype-Verbildung und so was. Und ich fand, das konnte man sich nicht anhören.
Stimmt. Deshalb bin ich ja schnell dazu übergangen, das nicht so zu machen. Und alle anderen auch. Also man hat sofort eigentlich das Gefühl, dass das nicht reicht, dass man will dann mehr haben.
Aber wie viel hast du denn jetzt in dein Equipment investiert? Oder mit deiner Erfahrung jetzt? Was würdest du sagen, wie viel muss man ausgeben, bevor man einen Podcast produzieren kann, der sich nach was anhört?
Na ja gut, man braucht mindestens zwei Headsets, weil man ja mindestens einen Gesprächspartner haben will. Und wenn man mehr haben will, dann natürlich mehr. Ein Headset kostet 250 Euro. Erstmal 500 Euro, dann braucht man einen Mischpult. Da gibt es natürlich schon, wenn man nur zwei aufnimmt, gibt es natürlich billigere. Hatt ich am Anfang auch so für unter 100 Euro. Inzwischen habe ich natürlich eins, was dann auch gleich aufzeichnen kann. Das kostet dann gleich wieder 300, 350 Euro.
Das hört sich aber dann schon wieder nach Elitensport an. Weil mal eben ein Tausie auf den Tisch legen kann, kann ja nicht jeder.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob man das unbedingt braucht.
Für einen Anfang braucht man das nicht. Man kann sozusagen klein anfangen. Vielleicht fängt man tatsächlich mit seinem Rechner einfach nur an. Und dann ab der dritten Folge will man dann vielleicht noch ein dediziertes Aufnahmegerät. Und dann fängt man an über Headsets nachzudenken. Und irgendwann hat man das dann zusammen. Das ist ja das Schöne, dass man sich das allmählich zulegen kann. Und wenn man merkt, es macht einem Spaß und man Feedback bekommt, dann kauft man eben mehr dazu. Man kann auch ein bisschen Geld natürlich durch Flatter einnehmen, aber das ist relativ wenig. Aber es reicht dann vielleicht auch schon mal nach drei, vier Monaten, wenn man viel produziert und viel Feedback bekommt, auch für den Kauf eines Headsets.
Wir haben zu dritt angefangen bei diesem Spaßformat. Es gibt so Großmembranen Mikrofonen, die man per USB direkt an den Rechner anschließt. Du stellst es einfach mit einem beiliegenden Plastik-Stativ auf den Tisch vor dich. Dann schließt es an den Rechner an und dann nimmst du es mit irgendeinem Software auf. Wir haben uns per Skype zusammengeschaltet und jeder hat sich zu Hause aufgenommen. Dann haben wir das zusammen in dieses Software geworfen. Dann hörte es sich an, als wären wir alle in einem Raum. Die Kosten dafür waren eigentlich 80 Euro plus für den Rechner, der dann schon da ist. Wenn der noch dazu gekauft werden muss, wird es natürlich teuer. Wenn man jetzt nur von der Audio her spricht, dann sind diese 50 Euro USB-Großenwarenmikrofone echt einen guten Klang für den Anfang. Man sollte sich vielleicht erst mal bei den Inhaltgedanken machen. Das geht dabei manchmal verloren, finde ich.
Aber wie war das denn bei dir mit dem Inhalt? Du hast selber gesagt, du hast dich nicht so quatsch gemacht.
Ich spreche aus eigener Erfahrung.
Um das noch mal kurz zu sagen, es war im Vorfeld der Sendung als verkündet, weil wer die Gäste ist, wurde gesagt, der Nikolas und der Richter kennen sich doch. Und die Podcast auch zusammen, das stimmt. Aber Nikolas ist vor allen Dingen deshalb hier, weil er einer der wenigen Leute ist, die nicht Tim Pritloff oder Holger Klein heißen. Und trotzdem aus eigener Kraft einen Podcast in die Welt gebracht hat, der relativ bekannt und vor allem auch sehr beliebt ist. Obwohl er nur ein paar Folgen hat. Das sind diese Elementarfragen. Wie bist du denn zu diesem Format gekommen?
Naja, es ist ein Interviewformat. Und das hat sich ein bisschen verändert auch im Laufe der Zeit. Ich wollte eigentlich erst auch ein bisschen inspiriert durch Tim Interviews machen. Also auch so Fragen stellen einfach Leuten, also Fachleuten zu einem bestimmten Thema. Das hat sich aber ziemlich schnell verändert in der Ausrichtung her. Da habe ich nämlich gemerkt, dass ich mich eigentlich mehr über persönliche Dinge unterhalten möchte mit den jeweiligen Gästen. Und eigentlich ist es daraus entstanden, dass ich mich gern mal mit den Leuten unterhalten wollte. Und ja, das ist so ein bisschen... Du kannst ja nicht jemanden anrufen, ich würde mich gern mal unterhalten. Und dann musst du das irgendwie begründen und dann mache ich halt eine Sendung. Und vielleicht ist es im Zweifel natürlich auch ganz spannend. Ja und sowas habe ich halt noch nicht gesehen in der Form, zumindest im privat produzierten Podcastbereich. Dann habe ich gedacht, dann mache ich das mal.
Wie einfach ist denn das, dass du rufst bei jemand anderem und sagst, ich habe hier diesen Podcast, ich würde dich gerne interviewen?
Ja, das ist schon schwierig. Also man muss da viel erklären. Das ist erstmal ein Podcast und man hat natürlich nicht dasselbe Standing, wie jetzt, wenn du sagst, du kommst von Radio Fritz oder so, dann bist du erstmal ein Radiosender.
Du bist halt ein Medientyp.
Du bist halt eine Institution halt irgendwie auch im Hintergrund und bist gleich seriös. Bist du halt nicht, du musst im Zweifel ein bisschen erklären, aber ich habe sehr gute Erfahrungen gemacht. Ich mache das meist schriftlich, um die Leute auch nicht so zu bedrängen und das auch gleich mal ordentlich zu begründen, warum ich die Leute frage. Weil den Leuten ist glaube ich auch wichtig oder den Menschen ist wichtig, dass sie sehen, dass man sich mit ihnen beschäftigt hat.
Also du schickst sozusagen gleich eine inhaltliche Anfrage los. Also sagst du irgendwie, ich bin der, der das Podcast bedeutet und ich möchte mit dir sprechen, weil.
Genau.
Und da hast du schon eine Ablehnung bekommen? Und aus welchen Gründen? Also haben die das begründet oder haben einfach gesagt, so nee kein Interesse?
Hauptsächlich keine Zeit, weil das im Endeffekt auch Leute waren, die viele Medien oder Presse Radiotermine haben und dann irgendwo sagen müssen, da machen wir jetzt nicht mit und dann sind es natürlich zuerst die Podcasts. Hoffentlich bleibt das nicht für immer so.
Okay, kannst du mal ein paar Beispiele sagen, wie du da so interviewt hast?
Die letzte Folge war jetzt Rainer Langhans, die hab ich erst letzte Woche rausgebracht. Fand ich insofern spannend als er da glaube ich schon...
Ich glaube, du musstest sagen, den Zuhörern eines Jugendradios kurz erklären, wer Rainer Langhans ist.
Das wollte ich gerade machen, ja.
Ach, danke.
Also Mitglied, man kennt die durch die Kommune 1 Studentenrevolte 68er. Viel mehr kann ich jetzt auch nicht erklären, das wird glaube ich eine Weile dauern, aber er hat ein gewisses Image in den Medien, glaube ich. In der Öffentlichkeit und alles. Ich war einfach persönlich daran interessiert, ob das dem so entspricht. Den Eindruck hatte ich nicht. Ich habe das Gefühl gehabt, er wird immer anders dargestellt. Und das ist auch ein gutes Beispiel dafür, was ich mit dem Format machen will. Also die Geschichte von Menschen erzählen. Das klingt jetzt ein bisschen hochgestochen, aber den Anspruch...
Also sagen, es geht dir dann nicht nur um die inhaltliche Form, sondern auch darum, ein bisschen Personality reinzukriegen.
Ja, die Leute kennenzulernen.
Das finde ich sehr spannend, weil wir sind jetzt an einem Punkt, und ich glaube, der wird uns heute Abend noch öfter begegnen, wo ich so ein bisschen hellhörig werde und denke, das ist doch eigentlich schon Radio. Also ich gehe zu einem Typen, der eine Persönlichkeit hat, um ein bisschen Lebensgeschichte und aber auch über eine Sache zu reden. Also diese Frage, inwiefern sich Podcasts und Radio unterscheiden oder ob das vielleicht tatsächlich sagen ein und dasselbe schon ist oder sein wird, finde ich nicht unspannend. Maha, nochmal bei dir. Du hast ja auch gesagt, du machst das mit Gästen. Du hast ja gerade auch erklärt, wenn man anfängt, dann braucht man gleich zwei Headsets, weil man will es nicht alleine machen. Warum eigentlich nicht?
Naja, man macht ja meistens so die erste Folge, um das Programm vorzustellen, alleine. Und da merkt man sehr schnell, das klingt irgendwie nicht so gut. Naja, es wird auch schnell langweilig, wenn da so ein Monolog gehalten wird. Das kann man nicht eine halbe Stunde durchhalten. Und deshalb braucht man eben irgendwie ein Gesprächsmann. Und dann geht das sehr gut. Also ich glaube zum Beispiel, weil wir bei den Unterschieden zwischen Radio und Podcast sind. Und ich glaube auch, Niklas nicht, dass er sich so zurücknimmt bei seinen Interviews. Ich glaube, ein Punkt ist wirklich, dass man beim Podcast auch als Moderator mehr als nur Moderator ist. Und beim öffentlich-rechtlichen Grundfunk ist es oft so, dass der Moderator wirklich nur moderiert. Naja, dass er halt moderiert. Das ist halt jemand, der nicht selbst Inhalte beisteuert. Und bei den Podcasts ist es oft so, dass der Moderator eine sehr starke Präsenz hat. Also ich meine, wir hatten vorhin Tim Pridlaff. Tim Pridlaff hat mir auch vorgeworfen, ich würde zu viel eigenes selber reden. Aber wenn man die Podcast von Tim hört, merkt man auch, dass er eine ziemlich starke Präsenz hat.
Meinst du, das macht einen erfolgreichen, also ich sag jetzt mal, erfolgreichen im Sinne von vielgehörten Podcast aus, eine starke Präsenz, die mehr sein darf, als es es in einem klassischen Radio gibt?
Ja, ich glaube, das macht das aus. Also es ist wirklich, wenn ich darüber nachdenke, wo sind die Unterschiede, würde ich sagen, das ist vielleicht nicht der wichtigste Unterschied, aber es ist ein Unterschied, der auf jeden Fall ins Gewicht fällt.
Wie kommst du denn zu den Gästen, die du bei dir im Podcast hast?
Na, unterschiedlich. Also es gibt natürlich bestimmte Leute, die man gerne haben möchte. Also ich meine, bei Liedkultur brauch ich halt immer einen Experten für ein Thema. Das ist halt schwierig meistens. Also ich wollte was über Kinotechnik machen, hab ich sehr lange gesucht, bis ich, also eigentlich über Kinotechnik, ich wollte was machen, aber das klassische, analoge Kino. Und da dachte ich mir, so ein Filmvorführer wäre ganz gut. Und das war unheimlich schwer. Ich hab dann aber schließlich doch mehr oder weniger zufällig jemanden gefunden. Und dann war das das. Und dann möchte ich demnächst nochmal was machen, über Motorrad fahren, Motorrad reparieren, also Zen oder die Kunst des Motorrads reparieren. Und da suche ich auch noch, falls sich jemand bemüht.
Der Moderator der Vorgänger-Sendung hat sich mit Motorrädern ziemlich gut umzieht beschäftigt.
Also das wäre zum Beispiel so ein Thema. Das ist natürlich auch wieder sehr technisch.
Wie fragst du die Leute an? Also wenn die jetzt sagen, du hast deinen Opfer gefunden, sag ich mal, wie gehst du auf die zu?
Na dann frag ich die einfach.
Aber auch so wie Nikolas, per Mail?
Per Mail, per Jabber und so. Also ich mache jetzt zum Beispiel was über Konzeptkunst, also Art Graffiti und so im öffentlichen Raum. Und da habe ich halt jemanden auch direkt angesprochen und er hat sofort Ja gesagt. Und das läuft dann jetzt live am nächsten Sonntag Nachmittag.
Das mit dem Live ist eine sehr schöne Überleitung. Vielen Dank dafür. Denn ein interessanter Punkt, der sich beim Podcasten, ich glaube so in den letzten ein bis zwei bis drei Jahren herausgestellt hat, ist, dass etwas passiert ist, was man eigentlich gar nicht mit Podcasten verbindet, weil Podcasten ja anfingen mit, ich kann mir das runterladen und dann höre ich es, wann ich will. Da gab es auch einen schönen öffentlich-rechtlichen Slang für zeitsovereines Hören. Und mittlerweile ist es so, dass viele Podcasts live senden. Das sind eigentlich keine Podcasts mehr, sondern Sendungen. Und da ist natürlich auch dann erstmal wieder die technische Frage, wie kann man das überhaupt machen? Das klären wir dann gleich. Und dann auch sozusagen, warum die Faszination dafür so groß ist. Ihr könnt dann auch gerne anrufen unter 0331 70 97 110. Aber bevor das losgeht, machen wir erstmal das Fritz-Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr. Heute Chaosradio im Blue Moon, die Sendung jeden letzten Donnerstag im Monat, wo der Chaos Computer Club hier über so ein Thema spricht, was so möglicherweise ein bisschen was mit Technik zu tun hat oder dem seltsamen Internet, von dem immer alle reden, heute geht es um Podcasten oder wie hat Maha das so schön gesagt in einer Mail? Autarker Audioproduktion. Sehr schön. Maha ist zu Gast und Elektra, beide vom CCC. Und noch Nicolas Seemark, der einen eigenen kleinen Podcast hat. Und wir wollen heute quasi besprechen, ob es jetzt wirklich schon so weit ist, dass das jeder machen kann. Wir haben jetzt gerade schon mit der Technik angefangen, wo es darum ging, dass es so ein Hobby ist, das wird sehr schnell sehr teuer, wenn man da wirklich gute Ergebnisse haben will. Aber Nicolas meinte auch, es gibt irgendwie, was waren das, 50 Euro waren das? Unter 100. Unter 100 auf jeden Fall. Und wir waren dann geendet mit, also man muss was zu sagen haben, es ist schwierig Gäste ranzukriegen, also nicht ganz einfach, aber es geht auch. Also man muss sich nicht fürchten, Gäste anzufragen, oder? Machst du noch mal kurz?
Also ich hab auch jetzt, ich war jetzt noch ganz mutig und hab zum Beispiel mal bei Volker Beck angefragt. Und in der Tat, also sein Büro hat nach dem zweiten Versuch zugesagt.
Immerhin.
Also wird vielleicht im Januar klappen, ich hoffe.
Jetzt eine Absage kann es ja auch nicht sein.
Ja genau.
Wenn man das schriftlich macht, ist die Absage auch nicht so schmerzhaft. Dann kommt halt einfach nur nichts oder nein.
Du meinst, das ist wie beim Date?
Genau.
Man muss halt einfach fragen. Und dann mit dem Koop klarkommen im Zweifel?
Und wenn man nicht fragt, wird man verloren.
Also erste Weisheit des heutigen Abends. Podcasten ist We-Dating.
Wenn man nicht fragt, ist das immer ein Nein.
Ah, verstehe, verstehe. So jetzt waren wir gerade schon stehen geblieben. Mahal, als du meintest Podcast-Livestreamen. Also beim Podcasten war doch tatsächlich irgendwie lange Zeit das Besondere, dass man es halt nicht live hören musste wie in dem bösen Radio, sondern dass man es sich halt runterladen konnte, wenn man wollte. Woher kommt diese Live-Faszination?
Ja, es ist ja immer noch so, man kann es ja immer noch hören. Also im Neusprecher ist das ja zeit-souverän. Also man kann es hören, wenn man will. Und trotzdem ist es gut, wenn man es live macht, weil man halt noch einen zusätzlichen Feedback-Kanal hat. Also beim Live-Hören kann man ja eben direkt mit den Hörern auch kommunizieren, also meistens über das Netz. Also man kann natürlich auch Call-In machen, wie bei Fritz hier. Aber das ist halt immer ein bisschen schwierig. Also das wollen die Leute glaube ich auch nicht so sehr. Aber man kann halt im Netz halt so einen IRC-Chat aufmachen und dann gibt es gleich Feedback. Die Leute können direkt Fragen stellen, man kann dann auf die Fragen eingehen und so. Und das macht dann noch mehr Spaß. Also ich habe wirklich das Gefühl, dass das dadurch auch insgesamt inhaltlich besser wird, weil man einfach noch mehr Feedback hat und das unmittelbar hat. Und dann kann man es hinterher noch mal eben als Podcast bereitstellen.
Nikolaus, ist das auch so, dass es dann nur um den Rückkanal geht? Weil die Wahrnehmung, die ich manchmal wahrzunehmen glaube, ist halt schon, dass Leute das irgendwie geil finden, live zu hören.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, da kommt noch so eine emotionale Komponente dazu. Wir sind gerade wieder beim Piraten-Sender Powerplay gleich. Du hast dich so genannt, glaube ich. Es ist einfach ein gutes Gefühl, das direkt zu übertragen. Man muss ja auch sagen, Podcast live ist ja die Distributionsform. Es ist ja im Endeffekt in dem Moment eigentlich kein Podcast. Man sendet halt und die Frage ist halt, wie man das dann nennt. Aber in dem Moment ist es vielleicht dann auch eher Webradio, was man dann auch wieder als Podcast verteilt. Das ist so eine Begriffssache. Aber dieses Live-Senden ist, glaube ich, und zwar nicht nur auf der Senderseite, sondern auch auf der Hörerseite sehr spannend, weil die Leute das Gefühl haben, sie sind irgendwie direkt dabei. Und selbst wenn die Leute diesen Rückkanal gar nicht so sehr benutzen, ist es trotzdem ein anderes Gefühl, zu wissen, dass das gerade live passiert.
Selbst wenn sie ihn nicht benutzen, haben sie zumindest die Möglichkeit. Also ich glaube, dieser Kanal ist schon wichtig. Man hat die Möglichkeit direkt einzugreifen, als jetzt mal von der Hörerseite gesehen. Und das macht es eben auch so spannend. Man fühlt sich wirklich auch als Hörer wie in so einer ganz direkten Beziehung. Wenn man wieder in die Beziehung schaut.
Ich würde gerne in diesem Fall noch mal eins sagen.
Jetzt, hallo!
0331 70 97 110 Bei mir gerade auffällt, dass ich bis jetzt über dieses Thema nur mit Leuten gesprochen habe, die selber podcasten, aber noch nie eigentlich länger mit Leuten, die nur in Anfangszeichen Hörer sind. Warum hört ihr Podcasts live? Also wenn ihr dazu was zu erzählen habt, gerne 0331 70 97 110. Ziel der Sendung ist heute der kleine Einsteigerleitfaden. Podcasten für jedermann. Wir müssen was zu sagen haben. Leute anfragen, das ist immer eine gute Idee, weil es alleine langweilig ist. Ein Mikrofon kostet 50 Euro. Jetzt sind wir bei diesem Live-Stream. Und einen Computer braucht auch jeder. Jetzt sind wir bei diesem Live-Stream. Dann ist natürlich die Frage, kann ich das auch von zu Hause machen? Oder brauche ich dafür dann doch die teure Studietechnik? Dann haben wir uns wieder einen Telefonjoker an den Land gezogen, nämlich den Dennis Schulz aus Hamburg. Hallo und guten Abend.
Einen wunderschönen guten Abend. Oder auch der Schulze genannt. Der Schulze.
Hallo Mara. Podcaster pack unter sich, denke ich da mal. Du bist, wir haben uns über Twitter gefunden, was ja auch sein schönes Podcastwerkzeug ist. Du hast gesagt, du hast sehr viel Erfahrung damit, Livestream mit dem technischen Minimum zu veranstalten. Wie genau ist das dazu gekommen?
Ja, das fing quasi vor 10 Jahren an. Das war, sag mal, da war ich glaube ich dann, 2016, 2017 müsste ich da gewesen sein. Da gab es mal ein Projekt bei, kennst du das ja noch, NBC Giga. Genau, und da gab es mal so ein Projekt, das war so ein Spaßprojekt, da wollten sie eine Giga-Partei aufziehen. Und da ich dann halt mal angefangen hatte, ein Giga-Parteiradio, einfach mal spaßeshalber, in einem Jugendlichen-Leuchten halt produziert, mit einfachsten Mitteln quasi, einfach mit einem Headset in den Mikrofoneingang. Dann hatte ich zu Hause lokal quasi einen Windows-Media-Server raufgespielt und irgendwie einen 32K-Video-Stream erstellt. Das sah natürlich total scheiße aus und hörte sich auch total scheiße an, aber damit fing das quasi an. Das hat sich dann immer weiter hoch gearbeitet. Ich hab bis heute noch kein richtiges Mischpult an sich. Muss man wirklich mal sagen, mein teuerstes Audiogelät, was ich hier habe, wenn man Schleifwärme machen darf, ist ein Zoom H2, was ich hier habe. Das sollte dem einen oder anderen Podcaster sicherlich auch einfallen.
Aber jetzt nochmal für alle Leute, die keine Podcaster sind, aber möglicherweise damit anfangen wollen.
Genau, das ist ein digitales Mikrofon, also mit einer Speicherkarte, das kann per Batterie betreiben. Dort kann man zum Beispiel unterwegs zum Beispiel Mitschnitte fertigen von Interviews oder etc. Oder man kann natürlich auch via USB oder analogen Audioausgang eine Soundkarte reingehen und dann auch Livestreaming betreiben.
Das ist also so ein kleines Wunderwerkzeug. Wie teuer ist das? Hast du da eine Hausnummer?
Dieses Gerät, das Zoom H2, das kostet aktuell etwa 100 Euro.
Okay, also auch sagen nicht...
149 kostet es gerade.
Okay, wir wollen jetzt mal zum Livestream kommen. Sollst du jetzt sagen, wie du damit angefangen hast. Was brauche ich heutzutage, wenn ich einen Livestream veranstalten will?
Wir brauchen einen Rechner, das habt ihr jetzt schon wunderbar erklärt. Ich denke für die einfachsten Specke würde ein einfaches Headset ausreichen, das man sich überall kaufen kann. Ich habe interessanterweise mit dem billigeren Headset sogar bessere Ergebnisse erzielt, als mit einem teuren Sennheiser-Headset. Und dann braucht man halt noch entsprechende Software.
Ok, dafür bist du ja hier. Was heißt entsprechende Software?
Natürlich einen entsprechenden Encoder. Ein Programm, das aus den Autosignalen entsprechende digitale Datenpakete erstellt. Da gibt es zum Beispiel das einfachste, unter Windows zum Beispiel, war auch damals schon sehr populär, so einen Shoutcast-Encoder, den man unter Win-Empf starten kann. Win-Empf ist auch schon ein altes Tool, was immer weiterentwickelt wurde. Und damit kann man zum Beispiel zum einen natürlich auch Musik screamen, wofür man die G-Malicenz und dafür bezahlt, und zum anderen natürlich auch direkt halt das Mikrofon zum Beispiel aufnehmen und natürlich auch entsprechend live senden.
Okay, die Software kann das dann, aber das heißt ja, jeden Zuhörer, den ich habe, der kostet doch Bandbreite, oder?
Richtig, zum anderen brauchen wir natürlich auch noch einen Server. Genau, entweder setzt man den halt lokal auf, irgendwie auf einem lokalen Rechner, dass man dann auch diesen Rechner von außen erreichen kann. Hier ist natürlich immer sehr viel Grenzen. Die heutige DSL-Schlüsse haben ja sozusagen mal so ein MBIT, wenn man dann einigermaßen passablen Streamen aufbauen möchte, wie ich sage jetzt mal, als Hausnummer 128 KBIT als MP3, aber das ist auch schon ein unterster Bereich, kann man quasi zehn Zuhörer hosten. Das war es schon. Dann braucht man halt einen richtigen Server, der irgendwo im Rechenzentrum steht oder eine entsprechende Leitung mit entsprechenden Upstream.
Na, zehn Zuhörer sind ja schon mal mehr als nichts. Diese Software bei sich selber installieren und den Server aufsetzen, ist das was einfaches? Kann das jeder, der sich ein bisschen einliest?
Nö, also jeder, der sich ein wenig auskennt und ich sage mal, ein Windows-Programm starten kann, und kann zum Beispiel so einfach mal einen Shoutcast-Server starten. Das ist meistens vorkonfiguriert mit Standarddaten, wo man sich dann halt quasi auch schon auflocken kann, einlocken kann, mit diesem Encoder. Das ist eigentlich alles, ich sage mal, jetzt weiß ich nicht, kinderleicht, aber wenn man unbedingt wirklich Podcasts live senden will, kann man sich in die Materie schon sehr schnell einarbeiten und innerhalb kürzester Zeit auch on air gehen. Also dann würde ich jetzt nicht so das große Problem sein.
Aber wie kriegt es denn hin, wenn ich es dann doch mehr als die zehn Zuhörer haben will?
Da brauchen wir natürlich dann einen Server. Ich sage mal, es gibt im Internet einige Dienste, die bieten zum Beispiel Shoutcast oder Icecast-Server an. Da kann man quasi mieten für wenig oder auch viel Geld, nachdem was für eine Kapazität haben möchte, wie viele Zuhörer man technisch erreichen möchte. Na gut, preislich weiß ich da jetzt gerade keine Preise im Kopf. Aber man braucht halt, wie gesagt, einen Server mit einer entsprechenden Anbindung, um halt quasi mehr Hörer zu erreichen.
Okay, wisst ihr hier im Studio irgendwie was, was man da so preislich, Hausnummer, was so was kostet? Dazu kommen wir gleich, aber zu sagen, dass dieses umsonst zu sagen, das läuft ja immer über, ich kenn jemand, der macht da was.
Ich würd sagen, also ich hab einen Routeserver, der kostet 13 Euro und der ist mit 100 Megabit angebunden.
13 Euro im Monat.
Da muss man auch die Traffickosten halt entsprechend beachten, ne?
Der Traffic ist unbegrenzt.
Aber gut, das ist ja günstig. Also für 13 Euro im Monat hast du noch keinen, der sich drum kümmert wahrscheinlich. Dann musst du dich dann noch auskennen, dass du den Server irgendwie spielst.
Ich bin ja von Windows kennt.
Naja, also ich glaube, der Schulze hat natürlich schon recht. Also erstmal, wenn man so eine Software zum Klicken, die gibt's halt massenweise, gibt's für Mac zum Beispiel Nicecast, das ist sogar umsonst das Programm. Wenn man bis zu einer Stunde nur produzieren will, dann muss man irgendwie, kostet 46 Euro.
Und unter Linux gibt's da zum Beispiel die Inter-TJ-Konsole, die man sich ganz einfach über die Paketquellen runterladen kann.
Ja, also da haben wir jetzt schon alle drei Welten. Und dann fängt man halt klein an. Also das ist auch nicht so schlimm, wenn man erstmal nur mit zehn Leuten anfängt. Und wenn man dann was Gutes produziert, dann kennt auch irgendjemand jemand anderen und dann ergibt sich das auch von selbst.
Jetzt ist es ja gerade, wenn ich sozusagen ganz klein anfange, dass diese Bandbreite, wie gut ich das Audio ausspiele, was ich produziere, da möchte man dann so klein wie möglich gehen, um vielleicht auch 20 Leute unterzubringen. Jetzt hast du gerade gesagt, Dennis, 128 Kilobit pro Sekunde im MP3, das kommt mir schon ein bisschen viel vor, weil das machen wir hier bei Fritz sozusagen für den Livestream, glaube ich, auch. Und das ist ja schon ein sehr gutes Signal. Geht das nicht noch sozusagen nur mal kleiner, also bis wann ist es denn hörbar?
Also qualitativ ist eine 128-Kabit eigentlich schon für mich persönlich die unterste Gänze. Man kann es natürlich auch runterstellen, wenn man es wirklich nur in Sprache machen will zum Beispiel. Dann kann man auch quasi die Bitrate halbieren und dann auf Mono stellen. Dann hat man ja noch einen Tonkanal, bei Sprache fällt das nicht ins Gewicht. Dann hat man entsprechend noch 64-Kabit. Man kann allerdings zum Beispiel auch ein anderes Audioformat nehmen. Zum Beispiel AUK, was ein freies Audioformat ist. Oder auch das wichtige AAC. Bei AUK zum Beispiel kann man auch mit 32-Kabit im Monoverfahren noch ordentliche Ergebnisse erzielen. Oder mit 64-Kabit im Stereoverfahren.
Kann man das einfach so hören? Also sagen, wenn ich jetzt einen AUK-Stream anbiete, können Leute da einfach draufklicken und das funktioniert? Also ist das in der Betriebssituation?
Unter Umständen muss da noch mal ein entsprechender Player nachinstalliert werden. Also unter Windows-Bordmitteln, der Windows-Media-Player oder ähnliches kann das nicht abspielen. Das kann erst Win-Amp oder VLC oder andere Player.
VLC, M-Player, also das ist kein Problem?
Ja genau, richtig. Sollte man ja heute dort auch schon drauf haben. VLC ist schon ein Standardprogramm.
Windows-User haben in der Regel doch auch schon VLC installiert.
Na klar, sie wollen ja auch Pornos gucken. Was haben die denn?
Entschuldigung, also bitte, die Herren.
Aber generell ist mp3 vielleicht ganz gut geeignet. Weil der Durchschnittshörer, der mal ins iTunes-Verzeichnis geht, um nach einem Podcast zu suchen, der wird sich jetzt mit Ognor nicht so auseinander gesetzt haben.
Aber wir machen nie K.
Also es ist nur so, um das auch mal, die Positionen auch mal zu vertreten. Das ist genau mein Ansatz.
Jetzt reden alle gleichzeitig, das ist schon mal ein gutes Problem.
Wir klären das ganz einfach so. Ogg ist dieses Format, das ist gewollt, das ist sozusagen vom politischen Ideal her. Das ist gut, weil es ist offen und so weiter und so fort. Was ich gerne am Ende von Experteninterviews mache, ist, die Experten fragen, wie halten sie es denn selber? Nikolas, du streamst in?
MP3.
Maha, du streamst in? Dennis, du streamst in?
Ich biete MP3 und Ogg an.
Okay, sehr schön. Na, immerhin. Aber MP3 ist sozusagen schon das, was einfach alle verstehen ohne Mühe. Und gerade, wenn man ganz teilen anfängt, will man wahrscheinlich, dass die Hörer möglichst wenig Aufriss haben.
Und da bietet sich das Shortcut zum Beispiel an, weil da halt MP3 kam. Die Software ist relativ einfach.
Ogg hat den Vorteil, es klingt bei niedriger Bitrate wesentlich besser als MP3. Aber es ist halt nicht so weit verbreitet, es ist nicht so kompatibel, dass es den Nachteil der Mann hat. Meine persönliche Untergrenze ist etwa 20kW. Wenn man es auf 16kHz beschränkt und mono, dann klingt es immer noch ganz anständig.
Also so, dass man es noch gerne hört, oder so, dass man schon sagt, okay, jetzt hätte ich aber eigentlich gerne eine dickere Verbindung.
Gut, also ich zum Beispiel, ich bin viel unterwegs, ich bin in Drittweltländern und zum Beispiel den letzten Alternativlos-Podcast, den kann man sich da nicht anhören in der normalen Qualität. Das dauert einfach ewig und drei Tage, den runterzuladen, der Download bricht 120.000 Mal ab. Das geht dann sowieso nur, wenn ich den Download immer wieder resume, also immer wieder fortsetze. Wenn man den immer wieder neu startet, weil man kein, nicht das passende Programm hat, dann kriegt man den Podcast nie. Deswegen rechne ich den auf meinem Server runter auf 20 Kilobit und lade ihn mir dann runter.
Und da reden wir hier aber auch von Sprache? Da reden wir von Sprache, ja.
Also ich hätte wie so ein heißen Tipp, für den fasse ich kein Server oder ähnliches leisten kann. Es gibt auch im Internet diese wunderschönen Live-Videostreaming-Dienste, wie BAMP-User oder U-Stream oder ähnliches. Die könnte man quasi dafür ja auch missbrauchen. Man hat zwar in jedem Fall noch ein Bild, aber die Kamera kann man hier umdrehen. Und man kann halt wirklich so viele Leute erreichen, wie man möchte oder wie die Server halt hergehen. Und das ist halt für Ome.
Also wir haben zuerst U-Stream benutzt und dann haben wir halt statt einem Bild einfach unser Podcast-Logo eingeblendet. Und das war halt ein Flash auf der Seite.
Die Herren, da muss man euch erst ein paar Minuten lang treten, bevor ihr damit um die Ecke kommt. Klar, ein ganzes Streamendienst einfach. Sehr schön. Dennis, dir auf jeden Fall vielen Dank.
Ja, bitte sehr.
Viel Spaß beim Minimals-Stream weiterhin.
Das werde ich auch haben. Neue Projekte rufen und ich habe mich auch schon Prominenz gehabt. Unter anderem Bodo Ramelow von den Linken, falls ihr das kennt. So muss ich jetzt mal mit angeben hier.
Okay, das wird notiert und du bekommst ein Fleißbienchen. Dennis, bis dann. So, jetzt haben wir gerade auch schon darüber gesprochen, das Klang an. Ich war jetzt in Selbstverständlichkeit davon ausgegangen, wenn es um Podcasten geht, geht es natürlich um Sprache. Da sitzen Leute in Reden, das ist ja auch alles, was ich hier erzählt habe. Wie ist denn das mit der Musik in den Podcasts? Also ich weiß hier, dass wir hier bei Fritz sozusagen mit Musik im Internet übertragen. Das ist schon arg schwierig. Wir haben zum Beispiel diese Special-Sendungen, diese Musiksendungen, die jeden Abend laufen von 8 bis 10. Und die dürfen wir in einem sogenannten Musik-Loop-Stream anbieten. Das heißt, du darfst das nicht runterladen. Du kannst dir so eine Art Fake-Livestream einklicken, wo die Sendung halt läuft. Du kannst auch nicht entscheiden, wann du die anfängst zu hören. Das ist sozusagen die aus rechtlichen Gründen. Habt ihr euch jemals Gedanken gemacht über Musik in einem Podcast?
Ja, ich habe sogar versucht. Also ich habe ja einen Podcast gemacht über Gitarrenmusik. Und da sollten natürlich Beispiele auch kommen. Aber nun leben halt die Künstler meistens noch oder sind vor kurzem erst gestorben. Das heißt also da gibt es noch entsprechende Rechte. Also habe ich mir gedacht, da gibt es doch so eine Gesellschaft, die heißt GEMA, da muss man doch eine Lizenz kriegen können. Und siehe da, auf der Webseite wird tatsächlich eine Podcastlizenz angeboten. Aber leider sind alle Bedingungen, die dort stehen, nicht machbar für den normalen Podcaster.
Was sind denn die Bedingungen?
Die erste Bedingung ist der Podcast, also von Privatanbietern, darf maximal 30 Minuten dauern. Und meine Podcasts dauern so zwei bis vier Stunden. Also das würde gar nicht passen. Die nächste Bedingung ist, es darf den Podcast nur von maximal drei Links, also URLs, erreichbar sein. Und ich habe alleine schon vier Urls, auf denen er angeboten wird. Und dann kommen natürlich noch die Urschorten dazu. Also das geht eben auch nicht. Dann kostet das zwar nicht viel, nämlich nur zehn Euro im Monat. Die muss man aber so lange zahlen, solange der Podcast online ist. Und eigentlich soll der für immer online bleiben. Und das geht halt auch nicht irgendwie. Ja, und dann kommt natürlich noch das Hauptausschlusskriterium dazu, dass man, wenn man das auch noch live sendet, dann aber auch ein Webradio ist. Das heißt, man braucht eine Lizenz fürs Webradio und eine Lizenz für den Podcast. Und das ist dann doch ein bisschen viel. Also an all diesen Punkten ist es gescheitert. Und dann habe ich gesagt, okay, wir machen das ohne Musikbeispiele. Das ist natürlich dann blöd. Aber dann mussten die Leute halt links klicken. Das geht natürlich, aber das ist nicht wirklich gut. Was man natürlich machen kann, aber es ging für das Thema nicht, ist CC-Musik. Also Creative Commons. Das kann man machen, obwohl es natürlich da diese GEMA-Vermutung gibt. Das heißt, die GEMA kann trotzdem ankommen und sagen, Moment.
Da gab es doch neulich gerade erst diese Geschichte mit dem Typen, der in die Creative Commons Party geschmissen hat und dann trotzdem GEMA-Gebühren bezahlen musste.
Genau, da gibt es diese unsägliche GEMA-Vermutung, dass die GEMA erstmal davon ausgeht, dass da irgendwelche Musik dabei ist, die ja nun doch GEMA-pflichtig ist. Und dann muss man nachweisen, dass das nicht der Fall ist. Und das ist meistens schwierig.
Also Musik lassen wir lieber bleiben. Gehts um?
Selber komponieren und selber summeln.
Das ist ja die spannende Frage. Also GEMA-Vermutung, das könnt ihr jetzt sozusagen, also wenn irgendwelche Musik drin ist, also irgendwelche, dann könnte die GEMA quasi sagen, Entschuldige mal bitte, wo kommt denn das her?
Und wie ist es mit Zitaten?
Zitate gehen ihm nicht. Das war halt auch mein Gedanke, man könnte ja zitieren. Aber das geht nicht. Die GEMA erlaubt, das hab ich vorhin noch vergessen, die GEMA erlaubt sowieso nur anderthalb Minuten in privaten Podcasts und die müssen auch noch gekürzt sein, also am Anfang und Ende beschnitten und man muss noch drüber sprechen.
Ich warte ja eigentlich noch darauf, dass die GEMA mal mein selbst komponiertes Intro-Jingle irgendwie in Rechnung stellt.
Na ja, ich hab ja bei der Liedkultur einen Jingle von Beethoven. Also im 8-Bit Modus. Und der ist auch noch leicht verändert. Da haben sich schon Leute aufgeregt, dass das nicht original Beethoven ist. Aber ich hab mir gedacht, sicher ist sicher.
Vorsicht. Es tauchen sowohl hier bei den Anrufern als auch im Chat ab und zu die Frage aus, warum wir den und den Podcast heute hier nicht drin haben. Und ich finde, der Plan ist schon für diese Sendung, dass man sozusagen mit den Leuten redet, die sozusagen jetzt noch nicht die Vollprofis sind. Also weil Podcasts hat in Deutschland schon teilweise auch Ausmaße erreicht, wo die Leute das halt sozusagen für ihr Leben machen. Und auch in einer Art und Weise, wo man sagen kann, ok, da steht jetzt ein Studio von mehreren tausend Euro irgendwo rum. Und das heißt noch Podcast. Aber im Prinzip ist es ja irgendwie was Großes. Könntet ihr euch eigentlich vorstellen, das sozusagen, oder würdet ihr das wollen, davon zu leben?
Also ich fände es toll.
Ich habe ja schon einen Job. Übrigens war das nicht Beethoven, sondern Mozart. Ich kann nicht davon leben, weil ich dann solche Fehler mache. Also ich habe ja schon einen Job. Deshalb ist es doch schon eher bei mir Hobby. Aber klar, es macht mir natürlich viel Spaß. Ich könnte natürlich auch noch mehr davon machen.
Also, ich weiß nicht. Dafür mache ich es noch nicht lange genug und häufig genug. Aber es ist ja auch so, dass es durch diese Spendendienste, die hast du jetzt noch gar nicht angesprochen, oder irgendwie kamen sie schon mal auf, Fletter und diese Geschichten, schon so ist, dass es zumindest ein Zubrot ist im Monat. Und das ist schon eine sehr spannende Entwicklung. Und ich glaube, wenn man so ein bisschen Kontakt zu anderen Podcastern hat und man da mal erwähnt wird, dann kann man potenziell schon so eine kritische Masse an Hörern erreichen, die eventuell dann auch mal bereit sind, mal einen Euro fallen zu lassen von einer Sendung, die ihnen gefallen hat. Und das ist natürlich alles noch lange nicht in dem Bereich, wo man sagen kann, jippie, ich kündige jetzt und fahr jetzt mit einem Wohneinhänger durch die Gegend und sende von da. Aber es wäre toll. Und ein paar Beispiele gibt es ja auch in Deutschland, die...
Da sind wir aber auch schon wieder bei den Profis halt.
Naja, was heißt Profis? Also ja, gut. Ich weiß nicht, wann ist man ein Profi-Podcaster?
Wenn man davon lebt. Ach so, das ist so definiert. Ein Kumpel hat es noch nicht gesagt, wenn ein signifikanter Teil des Eilkommens damit bestritten wird.
Das steht irgendwo in irgendeinem Buch, dass das dann ein Profi-Podcaster ist.
Nö, das finde ich schon zu sagen. Würde ich jetzt so definieren, jemand, der so viele Einnahmen hat, dass es ihm wehtun würde, wenn die auf einmal wegfallen werden und sagen.
Ich bin nicht Profi-Podcaster. Wie viel kriegst du denn? Es sind ungefähr 200 Euro im Monat. Das würde mir wehtun, wenn die fehlen würden.
Aber ändert sich dann für dich auch das Podcasten? Das heißt, wenn du darauf angewiesen bist, hast du eigentlich auch Zwang oder nicht?
Nö, warum? Ich empfinde das eher, das ist auch wieder die Frage, ist das eine Bezahlung? Was ist dieser Betrag, der da reinkommt? Das ist ja kein Gehalt, der mir bezahlt wird und einen gewissen Druck hat. Ich empfinde das als eine Art Bedanken für das, was ich gemacht habe. Und irgendwie einen Ansporn weiterzumachen.
Na gut, aber das heißt, wenn das wegfallen würde, würde es dich schmerzen, weil du sagen würdest, der Dank dann nicht mehr da ist, aber du könntest ja noch ohne weiterleben.
Ich könnte schon ohne weiterleben.
Genau, das meine ich so zu sagen. Wenn das nicht der Fall wäre, dann wärst du ein Profi. So kriegst du ganz schön fette Dankeschön geschenkt. Wie ist denn das ansonsten? Marius, du hast auch erzählt, das Feedback ist ja quasi dann auch ein bisschen das Futter für Podcasten. Wie sind denn die Reaktionen der Leute?
Ja, da kommen halt immer Reaktionen. Also bei dieser Live-Geschichte kommt natürlich deutlich mehr, weil ja eben auch noch die Live-Reaktion dabei ist. Da ist auch irgendwie so eine, plötzlich gleich so eine Community da. Das sind halt im Chat auch immer dieselben Leute. Das ist aber auch ganz nett irgendwie. Und dann gibt es natürlich die Kommentarfunktion und so. Gut, natürlich könnte das immer mehr sein, als man hat. Aber ich finde das wirklich sehr befriedigend, das zu bekommen. Und dank Flatter gibt es eben auch ein bisschen Geld. Das ist bei mir allerdings deutlich weniger natürlich. Aber das ist einfach schön, wenn da ein paar Klicks kommen. Also einfach die Zahl der Klicks freut mich da schon. Auf dem Flatter-Button, weil das einfach schon an sich eine gewisse Anerkennung ist.
Wie fühlt sich das für dich an? Wenn du Geld dafür kriegst, erinnert sich dann für dich irgendwas? Es gab ja mal eine Zeit im Internet, die ist noch nicht so lange her, da haben alle sofort, wenn irgendwo nur ein Werbebanner zu sehen war, oder irgendwie ein Paypal-Button oder was auch immer, wurde man richtig so ausverkauft, das geht gar nicht.
Ja stimmt, das ist gesagt worden. Aber ich glaube, da ist Flatter eben ganz unaufdringlich. Ich glaube, das ist in der Hinsicht ganz was anderes. Das machen die Leute dann auch mit.
Aber für dich selber hat sich auch nicht dadurch geändert, dass du jetzt quasi...
Außer, dass Flatter nochmal eine zusätzliche Art des Feedbacks ist. Das ist ja viel einfacher für die Leute da mal zu klicken, als einen Kommentar zu schreiben. Also man kriegt dadurch eben auch mehr Feedback, weil man eben einen Klick kriegt.
Alles klar. Flatter, super Feedback. Also im Prinzip... Das ist natürlich sozusagen ein bisschen blasphemisch, das in einem Chaosrad zu sagen, aber im Prinzip sozusagen wäre so ein Like-Click wie bei Facebook auch etwas, was ein Podcaster freuen würde.
Aber ich bin ja Facebook-Ablehner.
Deswegen sagte ich das mit der Blasphemie. Gut, so jetzt haben wir also geklärt, was man für einen Podcast alles braucht. Das ist nämlich ein Thema, möglicherweise ein Gast, ein Mikrofon, was nicht ganz billig, aber erschwinglich ist, eine Streaming-Software. Da hat im Chat gerade jemand gesagt, ich soll noch Laudio, glaube ich, für den Mac empfehlen, was kostenlos ist und wohl ziemlich gut sein soll. Man kann auch über YouStream streamen. Und diese Live-Sache ist sehr gut und man soll Flatter einbinden, weil dann kriegt man nicht nur ein bisschen Kohle, sondern auch Feedback. Genauer gesagt heute das Chaosradio, wo es übers Radio machen geht, beziehungsweise um das Radio-Federmann machen geht, also ums Podcast. Und wir haben sozusagen mit der digitalen Version des Ganzen angefangen. Also wie nimmt man das auf? Man braucht ein Computer dazu, Mikrofontechnik etc. etc. Und jetzt ist es ja aber doch so, trotz dieses ganzen großen Internets, das da draußen unterwegs ist, wo man sich Sachen runterladen und auch live streamen kann, gibt es immer noch UKW-Radio. Und jetzt wären die Leute, die im Chaos Computer Club sind, nicht die Leute, die im Chaos Computer Club sind, wenn sie nicht probieren würden, alles selber zu machen, zum Beispiel auch einen UKW-Sender zu bauen. Dafür ist heute Elektra hier, die die erste Stunde ganz still war, weil das jetzt ihr Thema ist, nämlich sozusagen, jetzt haben wir das Audio, jetzt wollen wir es auch UKW in die Welt schicken. Das ist die erste Frage. Geht das überhaupt oder brauche ich dafür einen Zernsee-Turm?
Naja, abgesehen davon, dass es illegal ist, geht das ganz leicht.
Ich würde mit der Illegalität vielleicht die Diskussion, lass uns erst klären, was wir können und dann können wir hinterher klären, wie verboten es ist.
Im Prinzip genügen zwei Transistoren und ein paar Widerstände und ein paar Kondensatoren und ein bisschen Kupferdraht und dann kann man etwa zwei Kilometer weit funken in sehr guter Qualität. Also die Tonqualität ist wirklich sehr gut.
Also jetzt tatsächlich auch sozusagen in einem Frequenzbereich, den ein normales Radio empfängt.
Das ist erstaunlich einfach. Ja, wenn man weiß, wie es geht, dann ist es wunderbar. Es gibt verschiedene Bausätze. Es ist ja nicht verboten, solche Sender zu bauen. Es ist nur verboten, die zu betreiben, also die eine Antenne anzuschließen. Es gibt viele Bausätze. Viele Elektronikversendler haben sowas als Bastelangebot. Die Elektronikzeitschrift Elektor hat immer wieder Bausätze angeboten. Viele Funk-Amateure, viele Radio-Amateure tun das einfach irgendwann mal in ihrem Leben fast. Der ultimative Kick ist auch selber mal zu senden und nicht nur zu empfangen.
Aber ich gehe also auf das Internet, suche die berühmte Anleitung und löte mir das selber zusammen. Oder bestimmt mal so ein Bausatz und das war's dann.
Genau, es gibt da einen Design, den 2-Dollar-Transmitter. Den kann man für 2-Dollar-Materialkasten bauen.
Wie lange dauert das, bis ihn zusammengelötet haben?
Wenn man die Bauteile hat und die Platine, ich brauche dafür 5 Minuten.
Okay, wenn ich es zum ersten Mal mache?
Ich habe Workshops gemacht, wo Leute kollektiv sowas gemacht haben und in der Regel verlassen, so nach 2-2, 5 Stunden fast alle Leute mit einem breiten Grinsen an den Workshops.
Ich finde, es hört sich jetzt ein bisschen zu unspektakulär an. Ist das wirklich alles? Ich setze mich hin, löte 2, 5 Stunden, dann habe ich meinen eigenen Radiosender.
Ich muss da mal wobeikommen, glaube ich.
Ich glaube auch.
Die Schwierigkeit ist in der Regel, dass die Leute selber noch nie gelötet haben. Also die typischen Fehler. Aber ansonsten, der Bausatz, den wir gemacht haben, da muss man die Bauteile noch durch Löcher in der Platine stecken. Dann wiegt man die Beinchen um, dann sind die fixiert und dann muss man nur noch richtig löten und die Bauteile halt richtig rum. Manche kann man eben verdrehen oder auch vertauschen. Wenn man den 1 Megaohm-Widerstand mit dem 100 Kilo-Ohm-Widerstand vertauscht, dann funktioniert die Schaltung natürlich nicht. Deswegen verbringe ich dann auch relativ viel Zeit mit der Federsuche. Aber die Leute werden es wahrscheinlich nicht viel verwenden. Wäre ja auch illegal, aber die verlassen das mit dem Gefühl, dass sie eine Technik gemeistert haben, die erstmal für viele noch so etwas wie Rocket Science ist.
Das Ergebnis ist dann sozusagen eine Platine, wo Zeug drauf ist?
Ja, das Ergebnis ist eine Platine, die ist vielleicht 2 x 3 cm oder 2 x 4 cm. Und es gab einen Bausatz, den könnte man direkt in den USB-Port vom Laptop einstecken.
Wie kommt das Signal da rein, also das Audiosignal?
Das Audiosignal kommt dann analog über die Kopfhörerausgangsbuchse.
Also du sagst dir die ganze Zeit, illegal, illegal, illegal. Heißt das, man muss dafür so gemahlmäßig eine Genehmigung haben oder darf man das überhaupt gar nicht in Deutschland?
Machen wir mal die Ironietags an. Man braucht keine Lizenz, um eine illegale Radiostation zu betreiben. Deswegen bezahlt man dann auch keine Lizenz für die Musik, die man spielt.
Was heißt denn illegal? Wie illegal ist das denn? Was passiert dir denn, wenn du das jetzt in deinem Garten aufbaust?
In der Regel würde ich sagen nichts, weil es einfach unter dem Radar ist. Es gibt Leute, die das notorisch machen und die das auch mit großer Reichweite machen. Gut, so ein kleines selbst gelötetes Senderchen, das funkt dann irgendwie in einer Stadt wie Berlin vielleicht 100, 200 Meter weit. Dann geht es im allgemeinen Störnebel unter, zumal die meisten Leute heutzutage wirklich sehr schlechte Radioempfänger haben. Man kann 70 Euro für einen Radioempfänger ausgeben, der sehr gut ist. Da kann ich zum Beispiel im Zentrum von Berlin eine Station aus Polen herein bekommen. Die ist über 100 Kilometer entfernt. Die kriege ich rein zwischen den Häusern. Die kriegt man mit den meisten Radios niemals irgendwie zu hören. Mit so einem Radio geht die Reichweite schon etwas in die Höhe. Die meisten einfachen Radios können einfach diese starken Signale, die hier in der Stadt präsent sind, einfach nicht voneinander abgrenzen. Und da das schwache Signal herausfällt, dann also man geht da eh unter. Ein Autoradio ist ein sehr guter Empfänger, also wenn es ein brauchbares ist. Ich könnte jetzt für verschiedene Marken Werbung machen. Das habe ich glaube ich nicht angesagt.
Ich habe gerade den Faden verloren. Ich bin immer noch total fasziniert davon, dass es so einfach sein soll mit dem UKW.
Wir müssen es mal machen.
Wir können doch mal einen Datengarten demnächst machen. Also Donnerstags im Chaos Computer Club Berlin.
Der Aufwand ist es halt immer, diese Bausätze vorzubereiten.
Im Vorbereitungstag hast du vorhin auch gerade bei der Frage zur Illegalität des UKWs mit einem Buch von 1939 gewedelt.
Genau. Ja, bis 1996 galt ein Gesetz aus dem Dritten Reich. Das Gesetz wurde erlassen 1937 und sah Zuchthaus, schweres Zuchthaus, bis zu drei Jahren für das Senden oder auch nur den Besitz eines Senders, selbst wenn der nicht funktionsfähig ist. Also nur Teile davon.
Wobei zu klären wäre, was schweres Zuchthaus noch ist. Das ist noch unklar.
Das entzieht sich meiner Kenntnis, aber ich weiß, es gab auch Gefängnisstrafe. Ich würde mal vermuten, dass man da in einem Wasserloch hockt, das irgendwie zur Hälfte mit Matsch und mit Wasser gefüllt war. Keine Ahnung, vielleicht kann es da jemand drüber aufklären.
0-3-3-1-77-97-0, falls ihr schon mal in einem Zuchthaus wart oder wisst, was das ist?
Schweres Zuchthaus.
Schweres Zuchthaus, genau.
Es wurde in den 70er Jahren sowohl in der DDR als auch in der Bundesrepublik wurde das sehr drastisch verfolgt. Es gab unter anderem Berlin Sonderkommissionen, die versucht haben, Leute zu ermitteln, die aus politischen Gründen in Berlin illegale Sendungen gemacht haben, was natürlich in der DDR nochmal einen ganz besonderen Geschmack hatte. Also die Leute, die da in Prenzlauer Berg frühe beratenden Radio gemacht haben, die können da Geschichten von erzählen. Seit 1996 ist es eine Ordnungswidrigkeit, die im Prinzip bestraft werden kann, bis zu einer halben Million Euro. Aber die ganzen Leute, die sowas als Hobby machen und dabei erwischt werden, die zahlen zwischen 500 und 2500 Euro.
Und machen dann weiter?
Manche Leute wüssten gar nicht, dass es illegal ist. Tatsächlich? Typisch mal. Manche Leute machen das vielleicht genau deshalb, weil es da einen bestimmten Reiz gibt. Von Höherstrafen weiß ich nichts. Die Sender werden natürlich beschlagnahmt, obwohl das eigentlich illegal ist.
Du meinst, die 2-Dollar-Sender werden beschlagnahmt? Wieso ist es illegal, die illegalen Sender zu beschlagnahmen? Das hab ich jetzt nicht ganz verstanden.
Weil der Besitz dieser Geräte und der Bau dieser Geräte nicht mehr verboten ist. Also dafür riskiert man nicht mehr ein schweres Zuchthaus.
Forschungszwecken kannst du das doch bauen. Forschung ist erlaubt in Deutschland.
Es ist ja so, dass viel mehr sendet in unserem täglichen Lebensbereich, als die meisten Menschen wissen.
Zahnbürsten?
Vielleicht wissen die wenigsten Leute, dass ihr Radioapparat, wenn sie Radio empfangen, auch sendet. Weil die heutigen Empfänger, die meisten, die haben einen lokalen Sender und mischen dieses Signal auf ein bestimmtes Zwischenfrequenzsignal herunter. Und dabei entweicht auch immer Störstrahlung. Es wird auch immer unbeabsichtigt gesendet. Mittlerweile darf man ja im FM-Band senden, aber nur mit 50 Nanowatt.
Sind das dann diese kleinen Stöpsel für das Auto? Die Stöpsel da links ran, dann kannst du mit dem Auto radionieren. Sind das diese Teile?
Ja, aber die Sendeleistung beträgt 50 mal 10 hoch minus 9 Watt.
Das sind Nullen an der falschen Stelle, wenn ich den Techniker richtig verstehe.
Deswegen funktioniert das Zeug auch nie.
Diese Geräte, bei bestimmten Elektronikversendern gehen die Reihenweise wieder zurück, weil die Leute einfach sagen, das Ding funktioniert nicht. Selbst auf ganz kurze Entfernungen, selbst wenn es nur 30 Zentimeter sind, kriegt man das mit dem Radio kaum rein und das Rausch. Weil der Rauschabstand gar nicht ausreicht, um ein ordentliches Stereo Signal, was diese Geräte immer dann produzieren, sauber wiedergeben zu können.
Jetzt hast du gerade gesagt, 50 Nanowatt, wie viel haben die dann?
Das hängt von der Betriebsspannung ab. Wenn man bis 15 Volt hochgeht, dann sind das schon so eher 200 Milliwatt.
Das ist auf jeden Fall schon mal viel mehr.
Das sind sehr viele Größenordnungen.
Jetzt würde ich von dir als Erster, aber auch keiner von den beiden anderen wissen, was glaubst du, was die Faszination dahinter ist, an UKW zu senden? Balmah hat ja erzählt, das Geile am Live-Podcast ist dieser direkte Rückkanal. Und wenn man es digital hat, weiß man auch genau, ich hab jetzt so und so viele Hörer und so was. Aber anscheinend hat dieses UKW-Ding, dieses ins Ungewisse hinaus Blasen, so ein Reiz. Wo liegt dieser Reiz?
Schwer zu sagen. Mich hat immer fasziniert, dass Radiowellen an sich einfach durch den Raum und durch die Zeit bewegen und kein Medium brauchen. Sondern sie brauchen eben nichts, nur Raum. Früher, man redet ja heute noch von dem berühmten Äther, weil man gedacht hat, es müsste irgendeine Art von Substanz, ein Fluidum geben, was diese Wellen benutzen. Aber dann hat man irgendwann festgestellt, zur großen Enttäuschung, sie brauchen einfach nur Raum. Und irgendwie hat mich das halt fasziniert. Schon als Kind.
Ich glaube, das ist vielleicht auch so ein bisschen eine Generationensache.
Aber ich muss noch ganz kurz sagen, dir ist es eigentlich egal, ob dich jemand zuhört.
Ich sende ja nicht illegal, das ist ja illegal.
Aber wenn du es in einem Land tun würdest, wo es nicht illegal wäre, wäre es zu sagen, die Faszination würde dann daran bestehen, deine Information in den Raum zu senden, und es wäre erstmal egal, ob die irgendwo ankommen.
Unter Umständen, ja. Aber wenn natürlich Leute zugehören, wäre es natürlich umso besser.
Ja, ich meine, eigentlich könnte man ja das Argument anführen, dass es viel faszinierender sein müsste, ins Internet zu streamen, weil potenziell die ganze Welt zuhört. Was bei UKW ja nicht so ist. Aber ich glaube, das ist einerseits, also ich bin zumindest durch UKW sozialisiert. Und dann kommt da halt nochmal so eine Sache des zufälligen Einschaltens. Also wir sitzen jetzt hier und blasen das raus. Und es kann sein, dass irgendwo auf der Autobahn jetzt zufällig jemand hier einschaltet, der mit uns nichts zu tun hat und mit dem ganzen Thema nichts zu tun hat. Und man denkt hoch.
Und dann hoffen wir, dass es in unserer Sendung hängen bleibt.
Ja, aber so viel nicht zu Chaosradio kommen. Also ich hab das hier auf der Autobahn, im Stau vor Berlin, in Michendorf, hab ich Chaosradios zum ersten Mal gehört. Das war, weiß ich nicht, eine einstellige Folge damals noch. Und jetzt sitze ich hier.
Wie konnte das passieren?
Das ist halt in diesem ganzen Live-Podcasten eigentlich noch nicht wirklich drin. Also wir weisen jetzt auf unsere Sachen so hin. Vielleicht geht dann jetzt mal jemand hin. Aber das ist halt wirklich faszinierend. Das ist potentiell einfach in diesem Umfeld jetzt hier jeder, der noch so fern als diese Thematik jetzt gerade hier vielleicht reinplatzen kann.
In dem Zusammenhang sollte ich unbedingt noch Tetsuo Kogawa erwähnen. Das ist ein Japaner. Ein Anarchist, der berühmt geworden ist, dadurch, dass er so kleine Bausätze, also es sind nicht mal Bausätze, es sind Bauanleitungen, wie man selber solche Radiosender bauen kann. Nur mit wenigen Komponenten. Und die Platinen stellt man sogar selber her, indem man Platinenmaterial zersägt und dann so kleine Platininseln auf die größere Platine draufklebt. Und es war nicht illegal, das zu tun in Japan lange Zeit. Auch so Garagentoröffner haben zum Beispiel im FM-Rundfunkband gesendet. Und Tetsuo Kogaga hat eine regelrechte Bewegung damit losgetreten. Also es wurde irgendwann mal geschätzt, dass es 3000 solcher kleinen Piratenradio-Stationen gibt, wo teilweise Hausfrauen aus Hochhäusern heraus irgendwie den Block abgedeckt haben. Und dass Leute einfach selber Radio gemacht haben, das ganz spontan gemacht haben. Im Prinzip ist das eine Kunstform. Und eigentlich, das Schöne daran ist, es wird niemand einen Schaden damit zugefügt. So ein kleiner Sender, der stört kaum, zum Beispiel Radio Fritz würde er kaum stören, nur auf ein paar Meter wahrscheinlich. Und das ist irgendwie ein wirklich interessanter Aspekt. Und Tetsuo Kogaga ist in bestimmten Kreisen damit sehr bekannt geworden. Ich finde das eine schöne Sache.
Aber es geht doch auch irgendwie legal. Ich kann mich erinnern, dass ich vor drei Jahren im Sommer mal mit Tim Pötloff einen Podcast gemacht habe. Und da haben wir gleichzeitig bei einer Radioaktion im Prenzlauer Berg, die meiner Ansicht nach völlig legal war, das auch gleich in UKW gemacht. Und du selbst warst ja auch mal irgendwie da. Also da gibt es ja nun auch Möglichkeiten, auch legal ins UKW zu kommen, ohne gleich den öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk zu fahren.
Man kann Veranstaltungsfrequenzen beantragen. Also ich habe selber bei verschiedenen Radioprojekten mitgemacht. Herbstradio, Radio-Ref, Juni-Radio und so weiter und so fort. Wo man für einen Monat oder für sechs Wochen eine Frequenz beantragen kann. Aber das kostet dann schon auch immer richtig Geld, also so im fünfstelligen Bereich. Da gab es dann aber irgendwo Fördergelder irgendwie für diese Projekte und die wurden halt gefördert. So einfach ohne weiteres geht es nicht. Aber zum Beispiel auf dem Chaoscamp, kann ich mir erinnern, irgendwie vor einigen Jahren gab es glaube ich einen 10 Watt Sender und der war halt auch völlig legal, weil er eben nur für diese Veranstaltung irgendwie eine Lizenz hatte.
Auf diesem Chaoscamp auch. Da gab es die ganze Zeit, 24 Stunden, ich hätte bald gesagt 24, 7, aber das Camp hat nicht so lange gedauert, also Campradio. Das ist natürlich eine schöne Formel auch, weil man dann gleichzeitig lokal per UKW senden kann und ins Internet streamen kann und anschließend das noch als Podcast anbieten kann. Das heißt, dass man drei Distributionsformen hat.
Diese Sache mit diesen 50 Nanowatt, also das ist etwas, was mich persönlich vollkommen ärgert. Wir haben diese Regelungen nur deshalb, weil Leute für ihre Apple iPods überall auf der Welt diese Geräte, diese Minisender gekauft haben. Die waren zwar illegal, aber die wurden irgendwann im Nachhinein legalisiert, weil man konnte es nicht verbieten. Aber dadurch, dass diese unsägliche Beschränkung wirklich auf dem Dreck unter dem Fingernagel, den man mit einem Mikroskop suchen muss, beschränkt ist, sind die Leute, die diese Geräte kaufen, erstmal frustriert und vollkommen enttäuscht. Und irgendwie fände ich das wunderbar, zum Beispiel wenn jemand seinen Podcast hört und das mit seinem Minisender überträgt, dass das jemand in seinem Wohnblock hören kann, ohne dass er selber den Stream macht. Oder dass man ein Mesh-Netzwerk verwendet, dass man an seinen Router einen USB-Stick einsteckt und damit den Stream abspielt. Wo dann vielleicht sogar noch die Leute irgendwie die Playlist editieren können. Das wären alles wunderbare Sachen. Scheitert halt wieder an irgendwelchen unsäglichen Regelungen, die eigentlich wirklich niemandem nützen.
Ein Punkt, dem jetzt gerade aufgefallen ist, ist, dass das Argument für ein UKW, ist ja sozusagen dieses Reinseppen. Also man sendet das halt und dann kann halt zuhören, wer will. Und auch das ist wieder was, was ist so ein bisschen wie vorhin mit dem Livestream sozusagen. Der Podcast ist ja mal aufgebrochen auch, glaube ich. So habe ich es zumindest lange Zeit erlebt, um Themen abzudecken, die man in einem allgemeinen Radio nicht bringen kann, weil es zu viele Leute ausschließt. Und dann ist doch wieder diese Faszination dahingehend zu sagen, okay, wir möchten aber doch eigentlich irgendwie alle haben. Wie geschaltet ihr denn eure Sendung? Für alle oder für ein bestimmtes Publikum?
Ich weiß gar nicht, woher das kommt. Viele haben ja das gemacht. Es gibt ja viele Tech-Podcasts sozusagen. Gibt es ja ganz viele. Das war für mich so der Anfang. Mittlerweile weicht sich das so ein bisschen auf. Und ich hoffe eigentlich, dass das Podcast-Ding halt, dass Leute, die Podcasts machen, mehr Themen machen für Leute, die einfach mit dieser ganzen Szene erstmal nichts zu tun haben. Das ist primär erstmal eine Audioübertragung. Ein Weg, Audio zu übertragen. Und ich weiß nicht, warum das überhaupt inhaltlich an irgendwas gebunden werden soll und warum das auch überhaupt formatsmäßig überhaupt gebunden sein soll. An jetzt eine Gesprächsrunde oder was auch immer. Man kann ja ganz viele sein. Man kann damit eigentlich alles machen, was man halt eben aufnehmen kann. Und auch schneiden und produzieren kann. Und ich glaube, dass das halt auch ganz noch am Anfang ist, die ganze Podcastgeschichte.
Aber dann wäre die Vermutung trotzdem zu sagen, selbst wenn du über Häkeln, Gärtnerei, Modelleisenbahnen, Kaninchenzuchten-Podcast machst, würde der sich immer eher an ein Fachpublikum der jeweiligen Richtung widmen.
Nee, musst du es ja nicht. Du musst ja nicht sowas machen. Du kannst doch genauso wie im normalen Radio auch Themen behandeln, die jeden interessieren. Oder die zumindest eben nicht nur Fachidioten, in Anführungszeichen, spannend finden. Ich maße mir jetzt an, dass ich keine Zielgruppe habe mit dem, was ich da mache. Also mit den Interviews zum Beispiel. Das sind halt Leute, die sind interessiert an Interviews.
Wenn du jetzt aber dein Publikum beobachtest, findest du, dass es die allgemeine Bevölkerung ist? Oder rekrutiert sich dein Publikum schon aus dieser Internet-affinen Podcast-Hörmolte?
Das rekrutiert sich schon hauptsächlich daraus. Allerdings kriege ich auch eben das Feedback genau, dass das angenehm ist, dass sich das halt nur unterscheidet und sich nicht auf sich selbst bezieht. Also das merke ich schon.
Also man erreicht dann schon noch andere Kreise. Also wie gesagt bei der Liedkultur, das ist natürlich auch ein Podcast, der sich schon irgendwie an diese Internet-Nerd-Gemeinde wendet. Aber wenn dann so Themen kommen, also ich habe einen gemacht über Anime, da kommen natürlich dann die Leute auch, die sich für Anime interessieren und die sonst vielleicht nicht so Podcasts hören. Oder ich habe beim Clavautercast mal was gemacht über das bedingungslose Grundeinkommen. Und das ist unheimlich oft gespiegelt worden. Also einmal haben das andere übernommen auf ihre Seite. Dann haben das einige von den freien Radios auch in ihr Programm eingebaut. Und dadurch hat das eine unheimliche Reichweite bekommen. Und das hören dann eben auch Leute, die vielleicht sonst gar keine Nerds sind.
Aber wenn ihr die Sendung macht, gebt ihr euch dann Mühe, dass ihr denkt, wenn jetzt jemand das zu sagen hört, weil sie sich für das Thema interessiert, dann will ich das auch reingeholt. Also bereitet ihr eine einzelne Sendung vor?
Ja, sicher. Also ich denke, das machen wir alle. Und ich mache auch immer Shownotes, damit man nochmal nachgucken kann, wenn man irgendwas nicht verstanden hat. Weil natürlich nicht alles erklärt wird, wenn sich Leute unterhalten. Erklären sie ja nicht. Wir haben jetzt vorhin auch das Wort Mesh erwähnt. Das kennen ja vielleicht die Leute nicht. Dann kann man in die Shownotes da einen Link reinmachen, auf die Wikipedia am besten, weil man da weiß, das bleibt dann meistens erhalten. Man hat auch immer gerne mal was gelöscht. Aber weniger als jetzt irgendeinen Link. Und dann kann man das nachgucken. Also ich denke, das ist schon eine Möglichkeit.
Also man kann einfach alles machen, was man ansonsten eben auch machen kann im Radio. Die Frage ist halt, ob man die Zeit hat und das Geld. Und ich glaube, das ist so die Frage. Geld inwiefern? Na ja, wenn du viel Zeit investierst in irgendwas, dann musst du ja auch irgendwann damit vielleicht mal was verdienen, weil du sonst irgendwann nichts mehr zu essen hast. Sozusagen ganz einfach ausgedrückt. Ja, musst nicht. Jede Situation ist anders. Aber das ist natürlich so eine Sache. Wenn du das jetzt ständig machen willst, jeden Tag, eine Sendung machen willst, es gibt ja so Beispiele auch, vor allen Dingen in den USA, dann ist es natürlich schon eine Frage, wie kannst du dir das leisten?
Jetzt hatten wir es ja vorhin schon gesagt, die Frage, ob ich damit vorstellen könnte, Geld zu verdienen, das wäre okay anscheinend. Wie viel würdet ihr in den Kauf nehmen an Einbußen, um weiter podcasten zu können, wenn das nicht geht? Ist das schon so eine Sache für euch geworden, wo ihr denkt, Podcast, ich will das jetzt unbedingt machen, oder ist das auch so etwas, wo ihr leichten Herzen sagen würdet, okay, das ist mir jetzt ein bisschen zu aufwendig, ich kann mir das gerade nicht leisten? Ist das so eine Herzblutsache?
Ja schon, das hätte ich am Anfang ja auch nicht gedacht, aber nach inzwischen 77 Podcasts, oder mehr sogar. Also noch nicht so viel wie du vielleicht.
Ich glaube sogar mehr ehrlich gesagt.
Also das möchte ich jetzt nicht missen. Also das ist eigentlich eine schöne Sache. Also dann habe ich auch das Bedürfnis, wenn ich länger keinen Podcast aufgenommen habe, denke ich immer, jetzt muss ich mal wieder. Das ist schon fast zwanghaft.
Die sogenannte Rotlichtzucht.
Das sollte jetzt auch nicht rüber kommen, dass ich das für Geld machen will. Sondern das sollte nur klar machen, dass man natürlich, wenn man viel Zeit für Produktionen reinsteckt, dass das halt irgendwann gemacht werden muss und man ja auch irgendwie noch Geld verdienen muss.
Würdest du es weitermachen, wenn das Entbehrungen bedeutet?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also es ist eine Leidenschaft, das auf jeden Fall. Das ist ja eben großartig. Man kann auf einmal was tun, was sonst nur Leute wie du da hinter dem Pult machen können. Ja, da ist so ein bisschen so ein Elfenbeinturm aufgebrochen, wie es das Internet mit vielen Sachen macht.
Medien selber machen.
Genau, und das ist glaube ich so die Sache, die ist jetzt entstanden. Und ich glaube bei vielen Sachen, bei Blogs, bei Podcasts, kommt dann auch irgendwann der Moment, wo man merkt, dass es eine Schwemme an Sachen gibt und dann muss man irgendwie Qualität bringen. Und das finde ich halt ziemlich wichtig. Die Möglichkeiten hat man halt auch inhaltlich wirklich bei Podcasts.
Das ist eine spannende Frage, dass sich ja irgendwann so ein gewisses Niveau herausbildet. Also irgendwie so die guten Podcaster investieren halt irgendwie drei- bis vierstellige Beträge in ihr Equipment, machen Sendungsvorbereitungen, haben dann auch die bekannteren Leute am Start, weil die einfach selber auch bekannt sind. Dürfen die Kleinen dann irgendwie nicht mehr podcasten? Also glaubt ihr, dass dann sozusagen so eine Qualitätsverschiebung so, dass man so dann die Leute belächelt, die es einfach aus Hobby machen?
Also wenn ich was antworten darf, also die Qualität setzt sich da glaube ich durch. Also das ist überhaupt, es gibt zwar so Platzhirsch-Tendenzen glaube ich schon beim Podcasting, auch in Deutschland, aber da ist glaube ich noch sehr viel Platz. Und man beobachtet auch, wenn Leute was Ungewöhnliches mal machen, was ausprobieren, dass da schon genug Hörerschaft noch da ist.
Das Schöne ist doch, dass es jeder machen darf, ob man damit erfolgreich ist oder nicht, das steht auf einem anderen Plan. Was ist Erfolg? Wenn man eine Reichweite hat, würde ich sagen. Also ich selber mache einen Podcast, ich präsentiere jetzt meinen eigenen, er heißt Dogmatic-Podcast.info und ich habe nur eine ganz geringe Reichweite, weil meine Botschaft ist nicht sehr populär.
Hätte ich jetzt bei dem Namen gar nicht gedacht. Aber was heißt nicht populär? Kannst du ungefähr abschätzen, wie viele Downloads, Hörer du hast?
Das sind wahrscheinlich in der Größenordnung vielleicht von 50 Leuten, die sich so einen Podcast von mir runtergeladen haben.
Aber das zu sagen, ist dir genug?
Das ist schön, wenn es mehr werden. Aber ich verstehe schon, dass der Inhalt nicht so leicht viral wird und populär wird.
Aber 50 Leute ist doch auch schon was. Wenn du pro Episode 50 Leute erreichst, ist das doch eigentlich viel. Es gibt Leute, die haben Bücher geschrieben und veröffentlicht, die vielleicht nicht mal von 10 Leuten gelesen worden sind.
Das ist eine spannende Frage, ob wir bei Podcasts tatsächlich sagen, wenn diese Lust daran, dass es viele Leute hören, die könnte ja möglicherweise zu einer Boulevardisierung der Podcast-Szene führen. Wir kommen es gerade so vor, als ob es zumindest eine Zukunftsperspektive gibt, die nicht ganz unwahrscheinlich ist, wo Podcasts das selbe machen. Durchmachen wir es wie die klassischen Massenmedien, also experimentell, dann für jedermann verfügbar, also konsumierbar. Und dann irgendwann werden sich die Dinge durchsetzen, die leicht zu konsumieren sind, weil die so schön...
Das Schöne ist doch, früher war das so, die Deutungshoheit lag bei wenigen Leuten oder bei Staaten, die die Medien machen konnten. Eine öffentliche Meinung zu beeinflussen oder überhaupt Informationen in der Öffentlichkeit zu servieren, denen zugänglich zu machen oder sie ihnen aufzuoktruieren. Das war damit verbunden, dass man Geld hatte für eine Druckerpresse, Vertriebssystem, die Hoheit ausüben konnte über Senderechte. Ich meine, warum gab es denn dieses Gesetz von 1937 aus der Nazi-Zeit, wo dann während des Zweiten Weltkriegs Leute mit dem Tode bestraft wurden für das Betreiben einer Sendeanlage oder auch nur den Besitz von Teilen davon. Es ging darum, wer hat die Deutungshoheit. Und das Schöne heutzutage ist, dass jeder kann da mitmischen. Die Frage ist natürlich, wie erfolgreich wird es populär, werden die Botschaften ausgenommen, wie serviert man das, wie professionalisiert man das. Und da haben wir hier natürlich auch Leute, die es sehr erfolgreich machen.
Indeed. Wir haben jetzt noch einen Anrufer, den wir kurz vor dem Fritz-Info noch unterbringen wollen. Das ist Marvin. Hallo Marvin. Hallo. Du, ich werde nicht ganz schlau, die wunderbare Redakteurin schrieb rein, du podcastest nicht, aber beschäftigst dich mit Livestreams. Erkläre er sich.
Und zwar ist mir das Eingefahrene von fast ein Jahr war das. Da habe ich dann auch so angefangen, Podcasts zu hören. Und fand mit der Möglichkeit, live zu hören, sehr verlockend. Und dann habe ich mal geguckt, was man denn da braucht, um auch selber ein Livestream zu machen. Und bin dann unter anderem auch auf eine relativ neue Möglichkeit gestoßen, die es da gibt. Das ist ja das sogenannte HTCP Livestreaming. Es wurde von Apple entwickelt. Und das fand ich sehr interessant, weil man braucht halt nur einen eigenen Web-Server, wo man dann halt ganz normal Dateien drauf platzieren kann, um einen Stream zu erstellen.
Ich verstehe nicht genau den Unterschied zu dem Sagen zu anderem Streaming.
Also man braucht halt keinen speziellen Streaming-Server mehr, sondern halt einen ganz normalen HTCP-Server wie den Apache oder so, den man sich bei den meisten Hostern sehr billig klicken kann. Und dann muss man halt dann nur die einzelnen Audio-Segmente raufladen, also die Audio-Sachen, die man veröffentlichen möchte. Dazu braucht man halt auch eine entsprechende Software.
Ok, aber bevor ich es richtig verstehe, du lädst sozusagen fertige Audiodateien da hoch.
Genau.
Aber dann ist es ja kein Livestream mehr.
Doch, doch, das ist schon, weil es gibt halt eine Software dafür, die lädt dann, also das ist natürlich nicht ganz live, aber so zehn Sekunden Latenz ungefähr. Weil die lädt halt einzelne kurze, sehr kurze Audiodegmente hoch immer.
Und womit kann man das hören? Braucht man dann irgendwie spezielle Software für oder?
Ja, zurzeit kann man das eigentlich so fast nur mit Apple-Geräten hören. Das ist ja eine sehr blöde Begrenzung. Aber bald dann auch mit VLC zum Beispiel und so. Das ist halt wie gesagt noch sehr neu.
Okay, aber möglicherweise geht der Weg dorthin, dass man sagen, mit noch weniger Aufwand noch mehr Livestream kann. Und Marvin hat es schon mal ausprobiert. Vielen Dank für deinen Anruf und viel Spaß beim HTTP-Livestream. Wir werden gleich hier noch für die wesentlichste, wichtigste und überhaupteste Podcasterfrage ever klären. Und das ist, wie lange ist ein guter Podcast?
Zwei Sprechstunden.
Eine halbe Stunde haben wir noch hier im Chaosradio im Blue Moon, wo es heute um Podcasten geht, wo wir versuchen zu erklären, ob das wirklich jeder machen kann. Und die Antwort lautet bis jetzt Ja, weil die Technik ist relativ erschwinglich. Man muss ein Thema haben und möglicherweise auch ein Gast. Das kann eine ganz gute Idee sein. Und apropos, ich begrüße noch mal Nikolas Simak, den Podcaster. Guten Tag. Maha und Elektra vom Chaos Computer Club. Und jetzt haben wir schon die technischen Voraussetzungen besprochen und die Inhaltlichen und auch wie man das mit dem Publikum macht und wie man livestreamt. Die Frage, die sie jetzt noch stellt, ist, wie lange darf denn so ein Podcast sein? Also wenn man sich sozusagen anguckt, was so erfolgreich ist, dann könnte man den Eindruck gewinnen, je länger, desto besser. Vier Stunden, sechs Stunden, wer bietet mehr? Was macht ihr?
Ja, also ich finde schon, dass man beim Podcast die Chance hat, auch länger was zu machen. Das ist einfach eine ganz große Möglichkeit und das ist eben auch der Unterschied zum klassischen Radio, was ja immer sehr kurze Formate hat. Also wenn ein Thema richtig spannend ist und man gute Gesprächspartner hat, finde ich es auch gut, wenn das ein bisschen länger dauert. Also ich bin wirklich der Meinung, dass 3- bis 4-stündige Podcasts auch möglich sind, denn die Leute müssen das ja nicht am Stück hören. Also ich finde das gut, aber es gibt natürlich andere Geschmäcker. Ich glaube, Niklas hat es...
Du meinst, weil ich jetzt so gelacht habe? Nein, das hängt halt vom Format ab, glaube ich. Also das ist wie bei den anderen Medien auch. Es ist erstmal grundsätzlich toll, dass man die Zeit hat. Das ist erstmal spannend. Andererseits finde ich, also bei mir geht es gerade in die Tendenz, dass ich merke, ein bisschen strukturieren, ein bisschen knapper machen kann auch ganz schön sein. Aber das ist eben formatsabhängig. Ich glaube, man kann jetzt nicht allgemein sagen, das ist die richtige Länge für einen Podcast. Das ist irgendwie schwierig. Eine Gesprächsrunde, wenn man Zeit hat, ist toll. Das ist halt das Gute am Podcast.
Ja, man hat eben Zeit, wenn man nicht so Zeitdruck hat, dass man nach einer bestimmten Zeit fertig sein muss. Das ist eben das Gute. Das ist halt eine unheimliche Freiheit. Im Radio kommt dann der nächste Slot. Und hier kann man einfach mal drauf losreden.
Es gibt vielleicht eine Art von Format, was besonders gut bei vielen Leuten ankommt. Aber die Freiheit hat man, das zu machen, wie man möchte.
Ja, und ich glaube, es gibt schon Gründe dafür, auch mal zu kürzen oder sich im Vorhinein vielleicht Gedanken darüber zu machen, wie lange muss jetzt ein bestimmter Teil dieses Gesprächs vielleicht ungefähr einnehmen, um alles zu beleuchten. Und ja, also so komplett unvorbereitet reinzugehen, ist jetzt nicht so mein Ding. Und das würde auch bedeuten, dass man ausufert. Und ich weiß nicht, also ich bin schon für so einen Spannungsbogen, vielleicht sagen wir es mal so, das finde ich notwendig.
Irgendwann ist auch die Aufmerksamkeit einfach nicht mehr da.
Ja, das wollte ich gerade sagen, also als Macher, bei mir ist es sowohl als Macher als auch als Hörer, finde ich, ist eine Stunde so ein schöner Rahmen. Ich habe kaum etwas selber gehört oder auch gemacht, wo ich dachte, länger als eine Stunde muss man das jetzt machen, also als Podcast.
Aber woran machst du das fest, die Stunde? Das ist jetzt für dein spezielles Format, oder?
Nö, das ist tatsächlich einfach ein Gefühl. Also ich kann nach einer Stunde nicht mehr zuhören, da habe ich die Nase voll.
Deswegen nicht aufmerksamkeitsspannend, sozusagen.
Möglicherweise ist es nur das. Aber ihr sagt ja gerade sozusagen, die Länge kann gehen. Es gibt jetzt auch das Wort vom Laberpodcast, das kommt ja nicht von ungefähr. Wenn ihr Podcasts hört, wie lange darf es denn da sein?
Das ist halt bei mir persönlich, hat sich das eben verändert. Also früher fand ich dieses grundsätzliche Argument, dass es nicht lang genug sein kann, was man ja oft hört beim Podcasting, hat für mich auch total gestimmt. Und mittlerweile bewege ich mich ein bisschen davon weg, weil ich denke, ja, jetzt kommt doch mal zu Potter so ein bisschen. Also das kann jeder machen, wie er will. Es gibt auch Leute, die genau andersrum das sehen. Ich glaube, du siehst es anders.
Ja, ich sehe es wirklich anders.
Du siehst es vielleicht auch von der Macht. Es ist halt auch mal die Frage, macht man es für sich oder macht man es für die Hörer? Da muss man wahrscheinlich eine gute Balance finden.
Okay, ich wollte gerade sagen, ich mach es für mich. Also ich muss natürlich schon Spaß dabei haben. Aber ich denke auch als Hörer. Ich habe auch Podcasts gehört, die waren so spannend, dass ich gar nicht gemerkt habe, wie viel Zeit vergangen ist. Und dann war ich ja froh, dass es so lange gedauert hat. Und wenn es halt nicht gut ist, dann kann ich ja abschalten. Aber ich habe auch die Freiheit, jederzeit abzuschalten. Ich kann sagen, das will ich jetzt nicht mehr hören, ich schalte ab oder ich schlafe ein.
In dem Moment war es ja eine unbefriedigende Sendung. Also genau. Aber klar.
Und als Podcastmacher kann ich natürlich nicht abschalten, aber dann merke ich...
Das ist ja auch.
Man hatte den Eindruck, manche Leute machen...
Aber das ist da ja auch so. Manchmal ist es halt so spannend. Ich habe mal einen Podcast mit Philipp Banzo gemacht bei Küchenradio. Das war so spannend. Wir haben es selber irgendwie nicht so richtig gemerkt. Bei Philipp kann man erst mal ganz spät anfangen, weil er erst sein Kind ins Bett bringen muss und so. Dann haben wir irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, haben wir noch Vorgespräch geführt, haben wir irgendwie um halb elf angefangen. Und als wir fertig waren, konnte ich die erste U-Bahn wieder nehmen. Also das kann schon ausufern, aber das war dann einfach so spannend, dass wir das gar nicht gemerkt haben. Das ist dann wie so ein Raum-Zeit-Paradox, so ein Wurmloch. Dann fährt plötzlich die U-Bahn wieder.
Da waren auch Drohungen im Spiel.
Ich glaube, das kann man auch genauso wenig beantworten, wie man jetzt sagen kann, das ist die beste Länge für einen Blogartikel. Das hängt halt am Inhalt und an dem, was man machen will. Ich finde Laber-Podcasts total toll, also ich mache ja selber einen, muss ich ja sagen. Das hängt halt am Format. Die Frage kann man glaube ich nicht beantworten.
Wenn es jemand gelingt, mich 4 Stunden an den Lautsprecher zu fesseln, ist das gut, aber das kann man natürlich nicht ständig hören.
Das ist ja was, was ich noch nie verstanden habe, weil da geht für mich jegliche Dramaturgie im Gespräch auch verloren.
Das ist unterschiedlich. Es gibt Podcasts, die kann ich nicht mit mehrfacher Geschwindigkeit hören. Mehrfach sowieso nicht, also anderthalbfach. Also ich will jetzt auch keine Namen nennen, oder ich kann schon Namen nennen. Podcasts mit Fefe und Frank sind halt mit anderthalbfacher Geschwindigkeit nicht erträglich. Das geht halt nicht. Das liegt aber an dieser besonderen Art der Dramaturgie, auch der Kommunikation. Und andere wiederum kann ich, zum Beispiel höre ich sehr viel, HR2 der Tag und HR2 der Tag. Also ich will jetzt nicht sagen, dass das ein schlechter Podcast ist, aber das ist einfach ein Podcast, den kann man in doppelter Geschwindigkeit oder in anderthalbfacher Geschwindigkeit Probleme haben.
Was ist das? Also was ist das für Format? Was passiert da?
Na das ist so eine, ja das ist eigentlich Kulturradio mit Info. Also die machen halt immer ein Thema, auf ein politisches Thema jeden Tag, was gerade aktuell ist, sagen wir mal Bankenkrise und so. Und machen das so ein bisschen ja kulturell verbrennt, also wie Vögelton. Da gibt es also verschiedene Interviewbeiträge und dann wird auch mal ein Text vorgetragen zwischendurch. Da gibt es halt immer auch noch so ein bisschen was Literarisches. Und das ist halt, das plätschert halt so, dass man das ruhig mit anderthalbfacher Geschwindigkeit hören kann. Und dann ist es halt ganz schnell vorbei. Dann ist es halt in 25 Minuten vorbei.
Da würde ich ja verrückt werden. Was plant ihr als nächstes für das Podcasten?
Naja, wie gesagt, also Liedkultur, also um es nochmal zu sagen, 1337kultur schreibt man das, .de. Da mache ich jetzt am Sonntag was über ja so ein bisschen innegeile Kunst im öffentlichen Raum. Deshalb darf ich da auch nicht zu viel verraten, wo ich da spreche und so.
Denk sie!
Kann man auch im Stream hören. Das ist so ein Thema, was ich seit langem machen wollte. Also vor allen Dingen auch so diese im Grunde, das ist jetzt nicht direkt ein Hip Hopper, aber so diese Hip Hop Sache, Graffiti und so. Das wollte ich eigentlich angehen. Da muss man halt den richtigen Gesprächspartner finden. Jetzt habe ich einen Konzept Künstler. Das ist also nicht wirklich Hip Hop, also die Richtung. Dann, wie gesagt, Motorradfahren würde ich gerne machen. Da fehlt mir der Gesprächspartner. Dann würde ich auch nochmal Jugendbücher machen. Da fehlt noch der Gesprächspartner. Ich habe da verschiedene Ideen im Kulturbereich, für die ich noch Gesprächspartner suche. Aber da geht irgendwie alles beim Kulturbereich. Das steht vor allen Dingen an.
Ich muss ja ganz ehrlich gestehen, dass meine Frage nicht darauf hinausliegt, die Programmsache für die nächsten drei Wochen zu machen, sondern ob ihr an der Art und Weise, wie ihr podcastet, noch was noch was... Hörertalk zum Beispiel ist so ein Thema. Meint ihr, so etwas wird auch im Podcast kommen?
Das gibt es ja schon. Das macht ja dein Kollege Holger. Das funktioniert auf jeden Fall. Er hat jede Woche mehrere Leute an seinem Skype hängen. Er rekrutiert natürlich direkt aus seiner Hörerschaft, aber das ist ja auch logisch.
Bei Holgi ist es ja so, der hat ja schon sein großes Publikum. Jetzt nimmt er einfach in diesen neuen Raum mit. Aber glaubt ihr generell, dass das Format Hörertalk auch im Podcast funktionieren wird? Oder kommen wird?
Also ich denke, dass das Format, das geht schon. Also ich denke, das ist möglich. Da gibt es schon viele Beispiele. Und warum nicht? Also ich glaube ja sowieso, dass es so eine Annäherung geben wird. Man sieht es ja schon, Podcasts, also jetzt gibt es viele Leute, die streamen ihren Podcasts auch. Da haben wir schon eine Annäherung als Radio mit HL2 der Tag und vielen anderen Beispielen. Das gesamte öffentlich-rechtliche Programm scheint schon verpodcastet zu sein, mehr oder weniger. Und so gibt es da eine Annäherung. Und Talkradio und so gehört natürlich auch dazu.
Man sollte vielleicht auch nochmal iTunes erwähnen mit seinem Verzeichnis, was da nämlich eine ganz spannende Sache ist, was ja für den Podcaster vor allen Dingen irgendwie eine skurrile Situation ist, wenn man sich dann, da sind dann diese Charts, und dann sieht man dann, ja dann ist es eine Produktion von Radio 1 dann und danach kommst du dann, Maha, und dann kommt wieder, also da sieht man diese Vermischung extrem. Und das ist ja auch glaube ich ein Ort, wo viele Leute auch suchen nach neuen Dingen, nach neuen Podcasts. Und das ist halt eine ganz großartige Auflösung dieser hierarchischen Strukturen, die man da eigentlich hatte, was ich total spannend finde.
Aber apropos hierarchische Struktur, ist es ja tatsächlich so, dass dieses iTunes, also Apple quasi, da so ein riesen Daumen drauf hat, also quasi eine Monopolbildung, gibt es irgendwelche anderen Podcasts, Verzeichnisse oder irgendwas, wie das kommuniziert wird?
Das ist ja kein Monopol. Die haben halt als erstes die Idee gehabt, das mal vernünftig irgendwo einzubauen. Das kann ja jeder andere auch tun. Also das steht ja, anderen Betriebssystem entwickeln.
Nein, nicht Monopol im Sinne von, dass sie das technisch abschließen, aber das ist einfach die einzigen, in meiner Wahrnehmung zumindest, wo das überhaupt irgendwie passiert. Warum gibt es das nicht woanders?
Also eigentlich, das haben wir noch gar nicht gesagt, wenn man den Leuten sagt, wie macht man Podcasts. Also ist ja die Frage, wie wird das verteilt? Und was man halt braucht, ist halt irgendeine Blogsoftware, sagen wir WordPress und ein Podcastplugin. Und dann gibt es ein RSS-Feed und so. Und dann brauchen die Leute auch keine iTunes. Dann können sie einfach auf die Seite gehen und diesen Feed abonnieren. Und damit funktioniert das schon.
Ja klar, also das war jetzt auch nicht gemeint, dass sie es brauchen zum Hören. Das ist ja klar. Das ist halt ein Ort, wo man die gut finden kann. Und ich meine, es gibt Google. Und dann gibt es, ich meine klar, es gibt ein paar Seiten, ein paar Verzeichnisse schon. Also Podcast.de und solche Sachen, die sind mehr oder weniger schön zu benutzen. Und auch, naja, es ist halt ein bisschen schwierig. Aber es gibt ja auch zum Beispiel, gerade auf dem iPhone und auch auf den anderen Smartphones, glaube ich, sogenannte Podcatcher. Also eben Programme, die erst mal Podcasts abspielen. Und dann eben auch interne Suchsysteme haben. Und da kann man dann eben auch Sachen finden. Also man kann nach Namen suchen, man kann sich Sachen vorstellen lassen. Also Top 25 gibt es da und solche Geschichten. Also ja, es gibt da schon eine Menge Möglichkeiten, was zu finden.
Und was man vielleicht auch nochmal sagen sollte, weil du sagst, was sind so die Perspektiven? Ich finde ja, es sollte da viel mehr Crossover und Remixing und Vermission geben. Also ich hatte ja schon mal diese Sache mit dem Grundeinkommen, die dann auch in verschiedenen freien Radios gelaufen ist. Aber das sollte eigentlich so zur Regel werden, dass sich da alle austauschen und dass eben das eine auch noch woanders läuft. Und dass beim Streaming, wenn gerade bei so einem Streaming-Server nichts läuft, dass man vielleicht irgendwelche Sachen nochmal wiederholen kann und so. Also dass es da einfach mehr Vermischung gibt.
Das ist ja was, worauf ich noch warte, zu sagen, dass es demnächst mal so ein Streaming-Dienst, wo Podcasts live gestreamt werden, anfängt, einfach 24 Stunden ein Signal zu bieten. Also erstmal egal was das ist, aber ob das wirklich passieren wird. Und dann ist man wieder beim Radio, das finde ich schon sehr spannend.
Und ich denke vielleicht kann man irgendwann auch mal das UKW übernehmen. Viele Sender gehen in den digitalen Bereich, dann wird das UKW frei. Und da es diese Radios immer geben wird, zur Notbastelsicherheit, kann man doch da irgendwie auch noch UKW. Also da muss natürlich gesetzlich was geregelt werden, aber wenn da kein Bedarf mehr ist für so viele Frequenzen, da wird sich das automatisch ergeben.
Das UKW ist tot, lang lebe das UKW quasi? Aber der hat ja gar keinen Rückkanal mehr, der so wichtig war. Haben wir noch was vergessen zu Podcasts?
Da kann man sehr viel darüber erzählen. Außerdem, der Rückkanal ist ja nicht weg. Durch das Netz hat man ja nach wie vor immer noch einen Rückkanal. Das ist ja in diese Verknüpfung. Internet plus Radio. Und das wird dann das Neue.
Na ja, bei einem Livestream weißt du, wie viele Leute deinen Stream gerade hören. Beim Podcast weißt du, wie viele Leute den heruntergeladen haben. Aber hier im Radio weiß man ja nicht. Da muss man irgendwie höhere Umfragen machen. Muss man schauen. Das ist ja immer auch eine Schwierigkeit hier für jeden Sender.
Ja, gerade um diese Zeit weiß man eigentlich nicht so genau aus.
Genau. Aber wenn man da einen Rückkanal hat, dann sieht man ja, reagieren die Leute, reagieren sie nicht. Wie viele Flatter...
Aber du kannst nicht beziffern, wie viele von den Leuten geben dir ein Feedback und wie viele Leute hören einfach nur zu.
So, weil das ja auch die letzte Chaosradio-Sendung im Jahr ist, möchte ich gleich noch mal zu einem kleinen anderen Thema kommen, aber zuvor noch sagen, Abklus, Plädoyer für, ich sitze zu Hause und überlege mir, ob ich jetzt irgendwie selber Audio produzieren soll oder nicht. Herr Seemark.
Um Gottes Willen. Was soll ich denn jetzt... Was soll ich zitieren?
Meinst du mehr Leute, so ein Podcast?
Ja, also grundsätzlich ja bitte, weil das ist in der Entwicklung sozusagen diese ganze Geschichte und man soll sich da nicht scheuen. Und vielleicht auch einfach nicht versuchen, das, was es schon gibt, nochmal nachzumachen. Ich glaube, das wäre jetzt mal so ein Ratschlag. Das kann man natürlich machen und man kommt auch dadurch erstmal auf Ideen. Also meine Sachen haben sich auch erst verändert, nachdem ich angefangen hatte. Aber sich einfach mal trauen. Und ja, das ist einfach mal zu versuchen. Und sich vor allen Dingen vorher überlegen, was man machen will. Das ist, glaube ich, jetzt heutzutage mal angebracht, dass man sagt, warum willst du denn podcasten?
Ja, genau, das würde ich auch sagen. Also es wäre wirklich sehr schön. Ich meine, das ist ja das, warum wir hier sitzen eigentlich auch. Also jeder soll eben der Sender, zum Sender werden. Also es soll wirklich jeder nach Möglichkeit podcasten. Gut, das wird nicht jeder tun. Aber wenn sich die Zahl der Podcaster so ein bisschen erhöhen würde, ist das, glaube ich, wirklich ein Beitrag für eine bessere Welt, würde ich sagen. Also von daher unbedingt. Also alle Leute sollten es mal ausprobieren.
Sendungsbewusstsein bekommt eine ganz neue Bedeutung und wird was Positives, nachdem es jahrelang ein bisschen anders besetzt war. Elektra, ich vermute, wir würden uns da in dasselbe Horn stoßen.
Ja, mein Podcast heißt Dogmatic Podcast, weil ich daran gedacht habe, unter anderem auch, es gibt ja diese Dogma-Reihe. Man braucht nicht, um einen Film zu drehen, immer das teuerste Equipment. Man muss nicht alle Einstellungen irgendwie von der Schiene ausdrehen und einen technischen Totschlag betreiben. Im Prinzip reicht ein externes Mikrofon und ein Computer. Und dann kann man im Prinzip loslegen. Ich weiß nicht, da seid ihr vielleicht anderer Meinung, weil ihr habt einen höheren Professionalitätsanspruch. Aber wenn jemand brilliante Ideen hat und brilliante Situationen schafft und ihr aufzeichnet, gut, irgendwann will man dann eine fantastische Qualität haben, vielleicht. Aber das muss ja nicht unbedingt sein. Die Dogma-Filme waren auch sehr beliebt, obwohl sie nicht mit dem hohen technischen Standard geglänzt haben.
Das kann ja auch einen ganz eigenen Charme haben eben.
Also ich glaube, dass die Professionalisierung, die im Podcastbereich in Deutschland irgendwie anzutreffen ist, vor allen Dingen auch der eine Gründe liegt, dass es viele Leute einfach total großartig finden, neues Equipment zu kaufen.
Ja, das sieht man auch. Dass es sehr viele Podcasts gibt, in denen sich Leute wieder über Equipment unterhalten. Gell, Markus?
Dazu möchte ich jetzt an dieser Stelle nichts sagen.
Und vielleicht möchte ich noch hinzufügen, da ich viel an Entwicklungsteilen unterwegs bin, ich hab das auch schon angeschnitten, aber es gibt viele Leute, die sind mit Internetbreitband nicht so wirklich gesegnet. Und die meisten Leute haben aber diese Leute nicht im Auge. Und vielleicht sollte man immer noch, also ich begrüße das, wenn Leute ihre Formate auch mit niedriger Qualität und entsprechend niedriger Bandbreite anbieten, damit ich die schneller runterladen und auch tatsächlich hören kann, auch wenn ich weniger Bandbreite hab. Ich denke mal, das sollte man vielleicht nicht aus den Augen verlieren.
Was ist denn so deine Detailgröße, wo du sagst, okay, das ist noch machbar?
Also ich hab für mich die Sachen runtergerechnet, ich hab das vorher erwähnt, 20 Kilobit OQaubis. Und damit es dann nicht nach Artefakten klingt, hab ich die Audiobandbreite auf 16 Kilohertz begrenzt und es ist mono.
Genau, aber was ich meine zu sagen, also das Audioverhältnis irgendwo hinstelle, wie groß darf das sein, damit es sozusagen keine Probleme macht? 5 Megabyte, 10?
Na, wenn es eine tolle Sendung ist und die ist zwei Stunden lang, dann ist sie etwa 15 Megabyte groß.
Das kann man also machen. So, also ich fasse mal zusammen, geht hin und sendet. So wurde das hier quasi in zwei Stunden genau erklärt. Ihr könnt euch das übrigens auch noch mal als Podcast anhören. Das gibt es im nächsten Mal auf fritzee.de und dann auch auf chaosradio.de. Der Maha hat im Vorgang zu dieser Sendung gesagt, er könne nicht nur etwas zu Podcasts sagen, sondern auch zu einer seltsamen Veranstaltung, die um die Jahreswende manchmal hier in Bedien stattfindet.
Manchmal, also zur Zeit auch immer regelmäßig. Das kann sich ja schnell ändern. Es geht um den Chaos Communication Congress, der halt immer nach Weihnachten direkt stattfindet, also vom 27. Dezember bis zum 30. Dezember. Das ist übrigens auch der Grund, warum das Chaosradio entfällt im Dezember, weil da diese Sonderveranstaltung ist. Die ist natürlich sehr voll, ganz schwierig an Tickets dran zu kommen. Deshalb werde ich jetzt nicht dafür werben und machen, dahin zu fahren. Aber, und jetzt sind wir wieder eigentlich beim Thema Podcasting und Streaming, also es wird natürlich live gestreamt von da und die Vorträge werden auch aufgezeichnet. Die gibt es dann nachher auch über BitTorrent und andere Möglichkeiten zum Download. Und da gibt es also viele interessante Sachen. Ist natürlich klar, in diesem Jahr, wo so viel passiert ist mit Staatstreuianer und ähnlichen Dingen, sind natürlich die Themen auch schon irgendwie gesetzt, wieder behandelt werden.
Gibt es da, sagen wir ab, von den offensichtlichen Verdächtigen wie dem Staatstreuianer, der wahrscheinlich ein, zwei, dreimal durch den Saal gekarrt wird, schon andere Vorträge, von denen du weißt?
Ja, also es gibt wieder die üblichen Verdächtigen. Es gibt wieder was zu GSM, weil da ja auch viel gelaufen ist dieses Jahr auf dem Camp. Es wurde ja sogar eine GSM-Basisstation dort fortentwickelt. Und das wird natürlich jetzt fortgesetzt, also zu GSM-Zumenge geben. Also vor allen Dingen Sicherheit in der Telefonie plus wie hacke ich das Smartphone. Also da kann man ein paar schöne Sachen erwarten. Das ist natürlich ganz klar. Ich werde natürlich wieder was über Sprache erzählen. Das ist natürlich klar. Und ich glaube, das Programm ist diesmal ziemlich bunt. Weil einfach so viel los war. Man hat irgendwie das Gefühl, dass in diesem Jahr mehr passiert ist als sonst.
Die Zusammenfassung gibt es dort. Gibt es schon ein Motto?
Oh, da ist noch eine Riesendiskussion.
Ich ziehe die Frage zurück. Wie hieß es in den letzten Jahren? Dragon's Everywhere oder Peace Missions? Gibt es sowas auch wieder?
Das wird es wieder geben. Und deshalb kann auch jeder teilnehmen. Weil es wieder dezentral diesen Kongress gibt. An verschiedenen Orten. Das wiki ist noch nicht am Start. Dann haben wir sehr spät mit den Kongressvorbereitungen angefangen. Aber es wird das alles geben.
Dann ist die letzte Frage, die mich zum Kongress erstellen kann. Wird das WLAN funktionieren dieses Jahr?
Du bist echt gemein. Das letzte Frage.
Wenn du ein Kabel mitbringst, funktioniert es.
Das WLAN-Kabel, das ist natürlich diesmal mitgebracht. Das wird schon irgendwie gehen. Da bin ich eigentlich zuversichtlich.
Dann sehen wir uns alle, wenn ihr mögt, auf dem Kongress. Dann gibt es nächstes Jahr im Januar vielleicht wieder ein Chaosradio. Gibt es euch schon ein Thema?
Wir können gerne noch einen Podcast machen.
Wir können ja unendlich abonnieren. Das war es dann mit dem Chaosradio an dieser Stelle. Hier kommt dann Flo Heiler mit dem Live-Vertrag durch Punk-Musik um die Ohren werfen. Das ist quasi die erste, letzte Sendung des Jahres. Viel Spaß allen Chaoten. Wir hören uns im nächsten Jahr wieder. Vielen Dank, Nicolas, Maha und Elektra, für's hielsein.
Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören und frohe Senden.
Don't forget I'm in your extended network.